Hello,
my friends were often running again,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can save yourself some money by
getting a free audio book and you can
also on top of that is if that wasn't
cool enough and also get three,
a 30 rather 30 days free audible
service.
Audible is a really a fantastic service.
Have a fantastic thing to have if you're
a commuter,
if you're stuck on a plane,
if you're on the bicycle,
just staring at a fucking stupid life
cycle thing telling you you're not going
fast enough.
Books on tape are an amazing way to pass
time and Scott Sigler is with us today.
We're going to get into that a little
bit later because a man has made a big
mark doing exactly that,
releasing his own books on tape,
you know,
mother fuckers,
audible.com,
forward slash go joe,
what?
What's my name?
My name is.
Go books on it and it's nocturnals on
there.
I'm right there.
Bam.
Um,
are all your books on there?
Nope.
No,
they're not all on there,
just nocturnal a contagious is on their
ancestors.
A trend.
Blood is red,
infectious,
contagious,
going to audible.com,
forward slash Joe.
Go there and get a free audio book.
There's more than 100,000
titles to choose from.
It's an awesome service and if you have
a whisper,
sync whispers thing is an app that is
amazing and what it does is you can
listen to the audio book.
Then you can read it,
you could read the book like it works
with the Amazon kindle fire Hd.
You read it and when you.
When you shut it off,
when you shut it down,
it picks up in your car or in your,
on your smartphone,
exactly where you left off the book
reading it.
It's amazing.
The audio accompaniment syncs up to what
you're reading,
so it's a really,
really cool service.
Audible.com
forward slash joe were also brought to
you by hover.
Hover is a domain name company that's
owned by the same people,
that own tank.
Our good friends who provide the ethical
cell phone service and hover takes that
same approach to domain name
registration.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com,
forward slash Rogan,
you can get 10 percent off your domain
name registrations.
It's a,
a very cool company.
The service is very fair.
They have a free who is privacy,
which usually have to pay for on a,
on other,
uh,
other services.
Very,
very intuitive.
I've registered websites there myself.
It's a,
it's an excellent place to register your
websites and they're a sponsor of the
show.
They support the show,
so we love them.
Hover.com,
forward slash Brogan.
Go there and get yourself 10 percent off
your domain name registrations this
Thursday night.
Uh,
there is a show at the American comedy
company in San Diego,
California.
If you're in that area,
it's going to be fun.
It's going to be brian red band on a
little buddy Brian.
Tony Hinchcliffe is there.
Of course,
lariats Tony Hinchcliffe,
one of the best up and coming guys
today.
Really fucking good writer.
Very funny kid.
Jason t dot,
who's awesome.
Of course you've heard him,
uh,
on our podcasts,
but I many the icehouse chronicles,
very funny guy,
real veteran of comedy,
Billy Ball now,
another very funny,
so funny man.
That dude's going to blow up that guy at
five years.
Huge.
And Yoshi,
who's awesome as well.
So that's this Thursday night at the
American comedy company.
There's still a few tickets left.
So jump on that ship bitch tonight or
tomorrow night,
Wednesday night.
I'm at the Ice House with Ari Shaffir
and Ian Edwards.
I was going to do one of those crazy
shows.
We're bringing a lot of people on
button.
I'm trying to work out all,
all this new shit.
So we're both,
we're all three of us going to do longer
sets.
Ian Edwards,
have you never seen him?
Really,
really funny guy.
And Ari of course is awesome.
So that's Wednesday night at the Ice
House.
Oh,
we're also brought to you by on it on
a.com,
which is um,
you know,
what the fuck it is.
Go there and buy some shit.
I said weapons.
People say we're selling weapons.
We're not,
we're selling fitness equipment.
And some of the best way to get
functional strength is with something
called a steel mace and yes,
if you want to box him in the head with
it,
it would be a good thing to box him in
the head with,
but that's not what it's for,
what it's for.
You fucks his functional strength.
What we concentrate on on on it is
things that improve your performance,
whether it's your mental performance
with nootropics or your mood through new
mood or your.
Your ability to perform at high levels
of energy for longer periods of time.
With troon tech,
what we're just trying to do is to
improve the way your body functions
improve your fitness and your health and
your fitness,
and that's what these may spells are
about.
There are these gigantic.
What amaze ball looks like.
It looks like something that you would
see in like a gladiator movie or a video
game as your first weapon.
Yeah.
It's like it's a.
it's a cannon ball on the end of a long
steel pipe and you swing it around and
do all these different exercises with it
and in controlling something like that.
It's surprisingly hard,
especially when you grip it like really
low on the end of the pole because you
have all this leverage working against
you and what it does is it gives you
real functional strength.
We have 10 pound ones and that seems
like,
Oh my God,
what?
Ten Pounds?
That's nothing.
Trust me,
try it.
It is.
It's such a weird workout club bells the
same way we have these steel clubs.
I use a fee,
a 15 pound one and a 25 pound one and
the fucking hard.
It's hard to do with like a really light
amount of weight.
It's all functional.
Shed a light like kettlebells,
like battle ropes.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Check out all our shit and if you use a
codename Rogan,
you will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
freaks.
We got Scott Sigler in the house.
We're going to get jiggy
with it.
We've got a lot of shit to talk about.
We're going to talk about some scary
shit.
I'm just kidding.
Experiences
powerful.
Oh,
after Scott Sigler,
you know you're a bad motherfucker.
When you look at the back of your book
and it says a worthy successor to
Michael Crighton,
powerful praise.
Right?
I know,
isn't it awesome,
and someone else has something super
cool about it was like,
Ooh,
look at that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty bad ass dude.
And you said a nocturnals being turned
into a TV show right now.
We're in the process of working on it
right now.
Yeah.
How much control do you have as a writer
when that happened?
I've been shocked by it.
Normally you have very little or no
control at all and a couple of points in
my career I've been very lucky to work
with people.
They're like,
let's get this as close to the vision
you want as possible.
And this is the guy who produced hellboy
in hell boy too.
And the watchman's name's Lloyd Levin
and Lloyd has been.
They've kept me involved at all phases
of this.
Right now they're fishing up the pilot
script for it.
So I don't write the pilot script,
but uh,
the guys who,
um,
who are writing,
it kind of sent me the plot steps.
Here's what we want the episode to be
like,
is that sort of match what you're
looking at and then because I'm writing
the Bible for it,
so we're going to look at the 12 episode
arc of the first season and make sure
everything fits in so we don't have any
crazy ending that doesn't make any sense
and then I get to give them feedback.
Well,
you could try these things and it's very
collaborative,
so that's amazing.
That's a beautiful thing to hear.
I love when you hear that.
It's one of the most frustrating things
to listen to when you hear someone who
had a vision and they tried to express
this vision to these other people that
had the money and the people with the
money like,
no,
no.
We got this.
We're going to fit.
We need a girl.
You need this.
You need a.
We need to add a black guy.
It works though.
I mean the guys who can raise
$20,000,000
get to kind of call the shots.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's,
it's a weird thing to see.
I,
I told this story before,
there was a,
there was a guy named Dave,
I don't remember his last name,
I apologize,
but he was a really funny guy and he's a
really funny actor.
It's been in a bunch of movies like real
over the top hilarious guy.
Well he got his first starring role in a
movie and I had a very small part in
this movie and I watched all these
people in suits.
This man had cuff links on like
beautiful,
like expensive cufflinks,
a perfectly tailored,
expensive fucking suit pin stripe,
a fat rolex with diamonds on it.
I mean this guy was fucking loaded,
right?
And he's doing like,
see?
He's like,
he's giving this guy like line reads,
telling them how to,
how he should do it.
Like I want you to come and like Whoa,
like thing that the guy thinks he's
funny.
He's actually,
he's got so much power and so much money
that he's.
He literally is telling
the comedian how to be funny.
And it was,
it was a horrific thing to watch.
It was the movie,
the movie was called Frank mccluskey CSI
or something like that,
but a terrible,
terrible,
and they gutted it.
They had two ideas.
They had one that was going to be a pg
13 and one was going to be pg or almost
going to be armed when they went
wherever they went,
less it went down.
It was.
It was all toilet jokes like you cut
them out,
you have nothing.
It was.
It was written.
You stop the people who are good at what
they do from doing what they do.
You hired them for that purpose in the
first place.
It's kind of counterintuitive,
but you got to think a guy who is such a
bad motherfucker that he did the
watchman,
that he produced the watchman.
That guy knows what he's doing.
He's.
He's brilliant.
I mean,
it's been great.
That's such a good movie.
It was an excellent movie and great
source material to start with,
but I'm a huge fan of hellboy when this.
When this popped up.
I mean I watch helpline like because my
style is super hard science space.
We try to make all the bad things
plausible,
so when you get to the nasty bits and
the bloods flying,
you're fully bought in,
you're like,
I know how I know this works.
I learned about this in science class
like that,
and you go watch hellboy,
which just a little bit more
supernatural,
but the creature effects in the way
everything was shot and it was just one
of the most beautiful things I've ever
seen to look up on the screen and now
that guy's interested in turning this.
It's like it could not wish for anything
close more closely matched.
Dad's kind of be an amazing feeling.
A perfect combination.
Yeah.
The Universe is probably about to send
an asteroid,
are way my fault.
Things are going to die and it's my
fault.
Sorry.
Yeah.
That must be very comforting to know
that you've got a.
A guy that's willing to listen to you.
I had the first book infected.
That was a whirlwind because I started
out giving all my books,
always free.
Audiobooks,
recorded myself.
Shot was podcast giveaways,
podcasts for free to build up an
audience because I couldn't get anybody
New York to pay attention because they
don't.
Well,
we don't know if your horror,
we don't know if your Psi Phi,
we don't know if you're thriller.
We didn't know if you're military.
All these different ass kickings genres
coming together so I couldn't get a book
deal.
Start giving the books away for free,
build up an audience,
landed a print deal with random house
for infected and part of that deal is
immediately optioned by rogue pictures
for a movie and that's the last I heard
it for like two years and I got to go
down and have a couple of meetings with,
uh,
with some people but scriptwriter and
never got to meet him.
Never got to see the script and
immediately just kind of went off into
the weeds and nothing ever came out of
it.
So this is pretty exciting so far to to
see things progressing.
Wow.
That's amazing man.
That's all I really don't.
Like I said,
that's an awesome thing to hear when
things are just falling into place in
the proper order.
Now when you write a book and then
you're gonna,
have your book turned into a television
series and you're sort of giving up,
you know,
your ideas to other people.
What,
how does that feel?
Is that a strange feeling?
Like what does,
what does that like?
Well,
this the second time around for me for
doing this and it is.
It's a little bit strange,
but largely it's very exciting because
what they do,
I can't do.
I'm not the guy
with the Rolex who's trying to control
things.
The,
the people who can paste this out for a
one hour television show and can kind of
visualize the twelfth episode arc and
then get someone to pay for it and get
it shot correctly and get up on a
screen.
That's a skill set.
I don't have it all,
so it's really.
I'm giving up a little bit,
but largely it's exciting.
Like I want to see the shit in this book
on TV.
I want to see it on the screen.
So it's a.
it's really not that nerve racking at
all.
You have no idea how it's gonna turn
out,
but at this point in my career,
I can see that I realized that the end
product,
I'm going to have a tiny amount of
control on it and you just kind of
hoping for the best.
You hope these guys got the,
they've got the right vibe and they're
going to want to put something as kick
ass on the screen is in the book.
Wow.
That's got to be a very,
very interesting process.
I wish you luck with that.
That's,
it's going to be a fascinating journey.
And tell us what is the,
what's the plot of the,
uh,
the book and a summary.
Not Turtle is a it,
it's a kind of a throwback to eighties
buddy cop movies.
And I grew up on know the whole trading
places.
Beverly Hills cop 48 hours on that huge
turn turn and uh,
just,
just love that genre.
So this starts out as sort of a buddy
cop procedural where there are,
um,
Brian clouser and Pooky Chang to San
Francisco homicide inspectors.
And Brian's having these really nasty,
nasty dreams about killing people,
and early on in the book they go to a
site and the murder scene matches his
dream exactly.
And suspicion falls on him immediately
that he's doing these borderline
superhuman things to go shred people and
body parts all over the place.
And then it,
it turns into the procedural from there,
they kind of have to follow the rabbit
trail and it gets,
uh,
it,
it's hard to.
It's hard to summarize it without giving
a spoiling it,
but it,
it gets kind of paranormal,
not really the supernatural.
There's a rational explanation for
everything,
but they uncover this massive conspiracy
within the police department.
There's been a coverup that's been going
on for,
for 200 years to stop this,
to let this particular group of people
who are sacrificing innocence,
let them continue to sacrifice Brian.
But you gotta figure out how to shut
that down and stay alive.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's some deep conspiratorial shit,
man.
Two hundred years of people keeping
their mouth shut.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it,
it plays off of the police department
and one is as researching this,
one of the phrases that came up,
like the biggest gang in New York is the
cops and that goes back to when they
first put in the police department and
they start to get a lot of power.
Uh,
the organized crime and the gangs were,
you can get away with a lot of,
a lot of stuff,
but at some point if you crossed the
cops,
whether they be good,
cops are corrupt cops,
you were screwed because you just had a
level of power you couldn't match so
that,
that they're the ones who have been
keeping this thing quiet because there
are a pattern of serial killers in San
Francisco and this other organization
has a way of getting rid of the serial
killers when the cops can't even find
them.
So the cops were actually trying to
keep,
keep this quiet and protect it because
the end result is more people live in
less people die,
but it's completely illegal as hell.
When you write a book like this,
how much,
when you're looking at human corruption
and cop corruption,
how much did you investigate the Jew go
and look at actual cases to find out
what's plausible or do you just go
completely on your instincts and what,
you know,
just by general information.
There's a significant amount of research
and it,
but it's broad.
It's not,
it's not deep.
It's broad research.
Let's look into what kind of corruption
there has been and how is organized
crime set up in San Francisco and
learning a lot of things that way
because fortunately at this point in the
writing career,
I've learned to try and stay away from
diving down the rabbit hole because you
can learn all this incredible amazing
stuff and then one percent of it
actually makes it into the book and all
the time you've invested in researching
that for these kind of thriller style
books is time that you.
Did you get nothing out of that.
So a lot of,
a lot of the superficial stuff learning
how,
uh,
you know,
the mafia was run out of San Francisco
and replaced by the tongues and the
Russians and in a lot of other groups,
all that stuff is super cool and a ton
of that goes in there.
And um,
the police department was pretty helpful
in,
in research for this.
There's not a it,
it's not your typical,
these are dirty cops and they're going
to shake you down.
They actually are trying to do something
that benefits the greater good,
but they have to totally ignore the law
they're sworn to protect in order to get
the end result.
So it's a bit more fun.
Corruption,
if you can imagine that.
Wow,
that's a,
that's a fascinating subject and I've
always been fascinated by like the idea
of secret societies that have been
around for 200 years doing horrible
things and pulling it off.
And usually you,
you know,
even in jest,
no one takes those things serious.
If you,
you know,
discuss skull and bones or something
like that.
Real police,
it's a fucking fraternity.
They do fall off there.
It's no big deal.
Illuminati,
all that good stuff.
Yeah.
But um,
the idea of it is,
it's a constantly fascinating source for
people because every now and then you
find one that's real.
Every now and then you find a,
like a Jerry Sandusky case where no one
really did tell the cops.
So for 20 years of trauma lasting,
it really did happen and you're like,
whoa,
like these things can happen.
Or the Miami.
Did you ever see Billy Corbin's
documentary cocaine cowboys for cocaine
cowboys won and cocaine cowboys?
Two or two of my favorite documentaries
ever.
They're amazing.
And uh,
this guy,
Billy Corbin who directed it,
one of the things he pulled out was that
there was one year where the mind police
departments,
a graduating class from the police
academy,
half of them eat,
all of them either wound up in jail or
murdered.
Oh yeah.
For like half of them were murdered and
half of them went to jail.
Like the whole,
the whole thing was like a crazy
criminal organization.
Like the entire police force was
massively corrupt in the cocaine
era.
It's when,
I mean if you go to Miami,
have you ever been.
No,
never been to Miami.
It's,
it's avoidable Ed.
It's not totally necessary amount of
money involved.
Back then it was just astronomical and
you know somebody's going to bite on
that sooner or later.
The amount of banks there,
it's insane.
The per capita there are much higher
than anywhere else because they were all
laundering cocaine.
Money for real.
I mean that's really the root of it all.
I mean the,
the,
the actual impact that cocaine had on
the economy of Miami is undeniable.
But this guy wrote about how crazy the
police corruption was.
Bank debt or rather did this
documentary,
showed it.
It's so it's possible,
you know,
people can go off the rails.
That was just a couple of decades ago.
You know,
where you've got,
you've got the money and you've got the
power and they're isolated from a lot of
the self examination.
You know,
if you.
The question at the upper top levels of
the police department can make a lot of
shit go away.
You know,
that's,
that's the place it seems most likely
to.
That's realistic there.
They had their hands on the drugs or
hands on.
The criminals are hands on the money.
If somebody is going to go bad,
that's a good place to do it.
Yeah.
It's fascinating when you find out that
it's true though.
It's like,
wow,
corrupt cop,
bunch of corrupt cops.
Like they tried it.
You almost wonder why it doesn't happen
more often.
It probably does.
Yeah.
Well it probably,
they probably pretty good at,
like you said,
it's the biggest gang around.
Why would you want to piss off the gang,
you know,
plenty of little subtle corruption.
A little bit of this,
a little bit of the guys who can shoot
you and it's legal.
Thank everybody.
Knows at the end of the day.
Really got to be careful around those
guys because it can kill you and it's
okay.
We're licensed to kill and they can just
say you attack them.
You know?
I mean how many,
how many times we've seen a cell phone
camera of someone videotaping or cop and
the cop beat the shit out of the kid.
And then,
you know,
you hear from the,
uh,
the arrest papers that the police
officer lied,
that the kid attacked him.
A lot of the kids spit on him or said
something or there was a,
there was a guy and Alex Jones recently,
same thing,
these cops just,
they have ultimate power.
And when I know if that's a bad thing,
whenever any human beings got ultimate
power over other people and there's the,
the,
the thing people I think tend to forget
is there's millions of cuts across the
country.
And,
and with that many per sample set that
big and those opportunities,
some of those individuals or very small
percentage,
those individuals are going to take that
opportunity.
Some of them are going to be nuts.
You only hear about those guy.
You don't hear about the 900,
99,000
that are just,
you know,
doing their job and willing to take a
bullet for you everyday.
But yeah,
it's,
it happens.
Yeah.
And went to like a Christopher Dorner
case happens.
People go,
Jesus Christ,
this is,
this could be a comp to that guy.
How did that guy get through?
You know,
or what happened to him in overseas and
turned them into that guy,
you know,
who knows,
but how much of that plays a part of
your writing.
It just sort of in a broad educational
sense,
like you just pay attention to all that
stuff.
It's largely to weave cap,
history of reality.
I mean people are.
There's a certain amount of things
people are expecting from a fictional
novel.
Things that feel familiar.
While there's got to be some level of
corruption is one cops got to be a total
bad ass.
Somebodies going to rub some guys up
just because you're familiar with it.
You've seen that.
So a lot of those things go into.
A lot of them are invisible in the book.
I tend both with the science and with
culture is to put in a lot of things
you're already familiar with so that
you.
You're like,
okay,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
And if you say,
yeah,
20 or 30 times,
like I know that I know that.
Then when it starts to go up to the next
level where the crazy shit starts to
happen,
we've already got this rapport.
I've already got a rapport with you and
your you've allowed yourself to buy in
completely.
So having those elements like,
you know,
realistic police things,
actually using the real history of the
Mafia and San Francisco,
anything like that allows you to fall
further into the story.
So it's very important to use real stuff
and kind of create that illusion.
That's awesome.
Man.
I,
I've always wanted to be a writer in
some sense.
I've never had the time,
but I've always thought a bad awesome
thing to like
carb wrote a terrible script once,
but we can do that in a way up here.
We were talking about starting a new
show called getting my shorts were.
I talked to people who like say exactly
what you said,
we sound for 10 minutes.
I interviewed about the fiction stuff
that you liked,
the movie stuff you like,
et cetera.
Tell me you think this stupid idea.
We were talking about this and then at
the end like,
okay,
well let's throw out some ideas for a
story and I'll help bounce stories
together and then when we get done you
get up and walk away and then like a
week later I've got like a five,
10 page short story and then that's the
kind of thing that a human,
if you're close that joe got naked,
that sounds like it would be a fun idea
that you get to write a story without
the actual grunt work of getting down in
writing.
You come up with a big idea and then you
turn it over to somebody who does this
on a regular basis.
It's like exactly like taking lessons
for something like here's what I want to
do and wanted to have this and then this
guy in and this chick should get naked
because obviously that's very important
to his story and then this sort of
things happening and be like,
alright,
let's go see what we can do.
We'll go back and look that up.
There's so many fascinating.
Excuse me.
There's so many fascinating occupations
out there.
There's just not enough time in the
world,
but writing has always been a
particularly romantic one.
You know,
it's the idea of putting together
something that you know,
crafting a story entirely in your head,
slapping it down on paper and then it
exists entirely in the heads of the
people that are reading it.
It's a.
The romance of it is so utterly
overblown.
It's not.
If I've been lucky enough to do this
full time for five years now it's my
[inaudible].
All I do is my job and it's similar to
mma.
When you see the guys come in the ring
and you're like,
oh,
look at all this pageantry and all this
wonderful stuff and the spotlight's on
them and you know,
except for the ultimate fighter show you
don't see.
You don't see the years that go in.
Just getting crushed and working all the
time and all the sacrifice and all the
things you got to do and then you get
that moment,
oh,
the books in the store and I'm on tour
and that last two weeks,
and then you'd go right back into the
dungeon and do it some more.
And it's great fun job.
I don't want to do anything else.
I'm so happy to be doing it.
But yeah,
those moments of,
or like little tiny things that pop up
every now and then.
Yeah.
Well to everybody outside of it,
that doesn't have to do the work.
That's where it's romantic or can be
grueling sitting there smoking a
cigarette in front of your typewriter.
Like you're a hunter Thompson crap who
your favorite writers when you were a
coming up?
Uh,
definitely a Stephen King is the single
biggest influence on me watching his
ability to tell a story and
characterized and like a parent,
the thing that always mesmerized me
about him is he can take a secondary
character,
give you one paragraph of description,
like here's a vocal twitch,
here's a physical twitch,
and here's this thing.
They believe in that you've got,
you know,
that guy's name,
20 years later he's the master of that.
Um,
and then Anne McCaffrey was a huge Scifi
writer that the dragon writers per net
series.
So that was kind of the more of the
science fiction area of things.
And Tom Clancy was another big one too.
Tom Clancy's,
the ability to take thousands of
different things,
research them in detail and kind of put
them all together where they come
together at the end for a super over the
top ending.
Those are probably the biggest three.
And Jack London's and other gigantic one
too.
When I was a kid I read something
somewhere where they were criticizing
Stephen King's books and it was a,
in some.
I grew up in Boston and uh,
in Newton,
one of the suburbs of Boston and there
was a lot of snobby people.
There's a lot of people that were like
Stephen King,
like what base writing.
And I remember thinking that,
like,
why would you ever criticize a guy?
First of all,
so fucking prolific.
I mean,
and it's really fun stuff.
Like how stuffy do you have to be to not
appreciate a good Stephen King Book?
I,
you know,
it's,
he's on a completely different level
than say the twilight writer,
but you still run into that today.
50 shades of gray and twilight and these
books come out.
Uh,
and,
and they blow up because that resonates
with the end reader and all of this,
all this pompous,
arrogant bullshit about I'm writing art.
And you know what,
unless your book has sold a 200,
300,000
copies,
no one's gonna remember your name,
uh,
50 years you're going to be gone unless
you get your book dusted off somewhere.
So the guys who are actually making
stuff that resonates with people,
that makes millions of people extremely
happy to read it again and again,
and then go see the movies they get,
they get shat on all the time,
all the time.
And Stephen King now is getting an
enormous amount of.
He's getting as props now from the
industry,
I think.
But yes,
25,
30 years ago,
everybody was all pissed that this dirty
but kid from Maine came out of nowhere
and is eating all their lunches because
he writes great stories that people
love.
They were,
they were pissed.
They wanted those books.
So not him.
Yeah,
they're crazy.
If you read the shining and tell me,
sign an amazing.
But yeah,
the movie's Great.
But the,
the uh,
the TV show didn't really dig that much,
but the movie was that Jack Nicholson
movie,
although very different from the,
from the book,
but the books great.
My favorite book of his is misery.
Yes.
You go through misery and know and you
know he doesn't,
he didn't,
just with a story
there,
he actually played with the topography
on the page.
If you actually read the page,
Paul,
the main character has to write this
story for Annie and then they switched
font,
bring in the margin so it looks like
regular typewriter page.
And then as the story's progressing
letter start to fall off of the
typewriter and the farther and it goes
first,
it's the end and the eat.
Then the ell and as you get towards the
end of the book,
we're not only as Paul's real life story
happening,
but the fictional stories coming to a
conclusion to.
There's all these scrawled pencil marks
in there and just looking at the page
starts,
distress you the fuck out.
And it wasn't until like the third time
I read it,
I'm like,
because I read it once.
okay,
that was killer.
It was killer and read it again,
and then I'm like,
I'm reading third time,
like,
why am,
why am I so angry?
What is going on?
And I stopped and looked at him like,
it's just so even understands the art
form of what vision,
how visually things look on a page,
you know,
why?
Why is that?
Who's on all sorts of drugs and shit.
Back in the day he was on some heavy
duty Shit.
He said that.
I think it was Christine.
He didn't even remember writing.
It was.
One of them did or didn't remember
writing.
It is alive,
man.
I think he was just fucked up man.
He was,
first of all,
he did a lot of cocaine and smoked a
lot.
It was fascinating that you said that
cigarettes were one of the things that
he really missed when it came to the,
uh,
the creative process.
Are you talking about that with David
Lee Roth the other day?
That nicotine is such a huge part?
Yeah.
Process.
Well,
it's a,
I don't smoke,
I don't partake in it,
but there seems to be undeniable proof
that it's some sort of a mental
stimulant and it does something to
accelerate thinking or does something to
the mind because too many people,
but like intelligent people at Bertrand
Russell would,
wouldn't get on a plane if you couldn't
smoke in the air.
Like if it didn't have room in the
smoking section,
he wouldn't get a plant.
It was fucking poor guy was just
attached it to this 10 tobacco tit.
Try some nicotine Joe,
see if it,
it's just nicotine.
If it comes out of here and go fuck
yourself,
I'm not going to get me out of that
crazy horse.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
so many writers,
uh,
have been smokers,
you know,
but the thing about Stephen King and he
quit and so he still puts out great
stuff,
but he,
I think he struggles more.
Do you hear what he does though?
Supposedly,
I mean because this is a bit of teams
that he allows himself that one
cigarette every time he finishes a novel
under,
he writes so many.
No joke is like I wrote 32 novels today.
Yeah,
that's funny.
That's a.
that's interesting that he allows
himself one cigarette a year or so as I
guess he's probably kicking out about a
novel a year if not more.
He just.
He's got a different different style of
writing to when you can,
when you can effortlessly bringing the
supernatural the way he does.
There's not an enormous amount of
research that's necessary.
I know when he wrote the green mile,
he researched a lot of things about the
prison system and actual history,
but if it's a modern day go story,
you don't have to research anything.
You just sit down and do your thing and
then that
allows him to allow him to write a
little bit faster than a lot of people.
Did you ever read the Tommy knockers?
Oh yeah.
I love that one man.
He's got the best,
in my opinion,
the best supernatural a scenarios.
He comes up with so many different
maximum maximum overdrive.
Did you realize that?
Oh,
I love that movie and it's interesting.
Now I'm coming to my fifth and final
book with Random House and I write these
hard science techno thrillers with the
fuck ton of monsters and um,
and,
and super and you know,
have a science fiction stuff,
so they always start out normally like,
oh,
I've seen this before,
this the CIA CSI episode.
Then things go absolutely haywire and
you're in for the ride,
but I've been kind of Jonesing to get
back to the,
the Stephen King that inspired me when I
was a kid,
which is,
you know,
you can spend so much more time on
character and plot and developing things
if you don't have these large structural
organizations like the cops were trying
to get.
Like the one I'm writing now is
pandemic.
It's the final book and the infected
trilogy and I'm trying to get help on
what it's actually like in the situation
room and the series is taken itself to
that level.
But I don't follow politics for shit.
I have no fucking idea what I'm talking
about.
The situation.
You mean the situation room?
The President?
Yeah,
the White House.
The like the CNN show with Wolf Blitzer,
first buck infected is head.
Anybody reads it as read,
Stephen King will see the influences
plain as day because it's largely,
it's a one university of Michigan
linebacker who blew out his knee in the
rose bowl.
So never not to go,
never got to go.
Pro was would have been a number one
draft pick,
hands down,
but now he works in computer support
because he didn't finish his degree and
he can't play ball anymore.
So this is giant super dangerous guy
with a lot of rage issues and works
really hard to control his rage.
And then he gets infected by this,
uh,
this alien vector,
this other thing going on and it turned
and he spends a lot large part of the
book trying to not kill people,
but most of that takes place in his
apartment and in the town of Ann Arbor.
And that's the Stephen King Angle,
which is we're gonna take a small town.
We can develop this out.
I can do whatever I want and I don't
have to justify why isn't the swat team
kicking in the door?
And all these other things,
so now that I'm writing this complicated
crap,
the situation room,
like I think that's kind of run its
course.
I want to get back to the smaller cast
in the smaller towns.
I grew up in small town Michigan and I
think that's why a lot of stuff
resonated with me.
It's the same thing,
just a different accent and I want to
for the future,
I would probably try and get back more
into that,
that kind of thing.
I thought it was amazing that Stephen
King wrote so many books about a writer
from Maine.
Yeah.
It's like after awhile you're like,
come on man,
I really do.
And you've got another book about a
writer from Maine.
Like Jesus,
I know you want to write a book a year,
but fucking come.
I can't be a baseball player or a
fireman or some shit.
Yeah,
it's got to be a goddamn writer from.
That's why you got into the Green Mile,
which is about as different than
anything else.
He's written an amazing.
Christine is another one of my
favorites.
Have you read any of his sons work?
Joe?
Joe Hill,
yeah.
I've read a horns and have read the
first couple collections,
have the lock and key a comic book,
which is what he's becoming most well
known for it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He was the locking key comic book lock
and key is um,
uh,
I forget where the family originates,
but they wind up moving to a,
um,
a mansion they inherit in Rhode Island.
So it's very similar to,
forgive me,
lock and key fans by have this strong.
It's very similar to old school.
Stephen King,
small town family goes moves into this
haunted house.
It's kind of shining ask and there's a
lot of different keys that will open up
different rooms in the house and the
rooms in the house or all these crazy
paranormal portal type things.
But uh,
he,
the artists,
I believe it's Gabriel Rodriguez and
they both one eisner awards,
which is the academy award of comic
books for this.
So he's really,
um,
although obviously he's had an enormous
amount of press coverage from being
Stephen King's son and writing core a
ton.
He's also developed this comic book
thing with the Idw is the publisher and
it's an enormous,
enormous success.
I read the one,
I think it's called little yellow,
yellow box or something like that.
What is it?
I don't want to even give away what the
plot is,
but it was great stuff.
It's,
um,
I'll pull it up.
The dark tower series is that can the
dark.
I,
I read the first one a lot when it first
came out,
but all my friends are so addicted to
that series.
Have you read,
have you followed that?
I followed up,
I think through book six and then,
um,
I don't think it's a spoiler at this
point.
It's 20 years old.
There's a point in the series where
Stephen King actually writes himself
into the series,
so the characters are actually talking
to Stephen King who's going like,
wait a minute,
I wrote you guys.
And I was like,
okay,
that's just to Metta for me.
I,
I've,
I'm out.
But the,
I think the first three dark tower books
are the single best trilogy of,
of any kind anywhere.
Those three books are just f man,
if he just stopped right there.
So there's still a masterpiece.
The series went on,
I think the first three books or there's
never been anything better written in my
opinion,
so it's perfect.
Wow.
Yeah,
he was a bad motherfucker and still is.
Yep.
Heart shaped box is his heart shaped
box.
Yeah,
that was.
I read that one.
It's about a haunted funded suit.
Really,
really good stuff,
man.
He looks a lot like his dad too.
It's kind of creepy shades of his dad,
but he's kind of.
His style is unique.
I mean it's,
it's very much his sort of influence you
can tell,
but very much his.
Everybody writes horror is influenced by
Stephen King,
you know,
that's like,
Eh,
I don't know how to,
you know,
not be [inaudible] there's no way to not
be a lot of.
A lot of people get into it specifically
because you read those books or you read
Peter Straub or any of the other,
you know,
the heavyweights back and king's Day,
John Sol,
etc.
And you read those and those call to you
and you want to make shit like that and
then when you start making your own
shit,
well of course it's going to have a
little bit of that little bit of that in
there.
And king king,
rally mitsis influenced by a ton of
people and he's like,
if you read myself closely enough,
you see their stuff in the book.
It's just the way it goes.
Yeah.
He was actually a big proponent of
reading other guys' stuff to help your
writing.
I
read Stephen King on writing.
Oh yeah,
great book.
That's a.
It's a bible for me because it's
specifically because it gets rid of a
lot of the pomp and circumstance and
the,
you know,
the nose up in the air.
It's,
it's so blue collar and you know,
for a small town guy like me,
you read that.
It's like you can read on writing by
Stephen King and see,
stop falling in love with yourself.
Stop sucking your own dick.
Pardon the phrase.
You're not that important.
You're not that great.
Just tell the story.
Stop putting in words that are going to
make everybody realize how important you
are and just tell your tell your story
and that's like the main jest of it is
how to,
how to streamline everything and not be
a pompous windbag but still tell your
great story.
So it,
it really resonated with me
being a pompous.
Windbag is a problem and pretty much
everything is.
Oh,
can everybody,
everybody?
Yeah.
I actually,
I,
when I my podcast,
because I give away all my books is free
audio books.
I play up the pompous windbag that's
like the joke within a joke.
I come on and talk about awesome.
The story is going to be in all this
other stuff and the fans that they,
they eat it up.
It's funny.
That's my shtick.
I can't do standup,
but I can do that thing.
And because you're,
you get used to it after awhile.
You know when people get very successful
at something and then they start to.
They start to believe their own bullshit
and that's when you start to get that
crazy self-importance coming on.
And what the sad thing about that is
when you start to see people like that,
the majority of their fans are like,
oh god,
he was so awesome back in the day,
but now look at him.
You know,
it happens to a lot of people.
The pressure or something.
The pressure of a success,
I think.
Yeah,
the success.
I mean if you're surrounded by yes men
all the time and nobody's there
criticizing your ideas
and you're not objective and you know,
you don't sort of self analyze.
A lot of people don't like to self
analyze.
It gets them confused.
But we've all seen the,
the real life pompous,
windbag.
And it's a shocking thing.
Yeah,
it's so gross to.
One of the reasons why it's so gross is
because you hope and pray that you could
never be that guy.
You know,
you hope and pray that if the situation
was reversed and you were in his shoes,
that you wouldn't be possible.
It couldn't be possible.
I feel like there's a lot of you getting
your ass kicked early in life and just
failure after failure.
There's an enormous amount to be said
for trying things and failing as opposed
to people who like the first thing they
try out of the gate,
huge success and then you know,
then you haven't developed that,
that humble nature of I tried 28 things
in 27 of them failed miserably.
So this one thing,
I'm not going to get too crazy with
this.
You know,
we're having success.
Um,
you,
you tend to see that in hollywood and in
writing.
Some people come out of the gate,
get that big novel,
it blows up.
Then after that they don't have much
access and they can't figure out what's
going on because they think they're very
important in this amazingly
chicken j changed their own frequency.
they're putting out because of their
success and that sabotages them.
That's in that.
That's the sad thing.
That's what,
that's what hamstrings a happens to.
So many though.
Yeah.
To so many different art forms to music
musicians that happens.
So,
you know,
the guys that are the lead singers of
these big bands and they go fucking
loony tunes.
The band falls apart and.
Well,
what was it?
Was it partying,
drugs,
adulation.
Undulations a serious possibility.
Adulation is a big drug.
The scary one.
You can get delusional in that shit.
You know,
it's uh,
it's,
it's a fascinating one for character
development though,
isn't it?
It is.
You can,
you can play off them anytime you've got
a story where you've got someone in
position of power,
it's almost impossible to write them
from here's a normal,
humble person.
This position of power,
like if you're writing About,
you know,
the mayor of san francisco isn't the
story that the police chief of san
francisco,
it's almost impossible for them to get
to that position if they're a nice
regular,
humble person because at some point in
any political construct,
you have to become cutthroat and you
have to looK at other people as an,
as,
as an obstacle to be removed and there
can't be humanity involved.
Like everybody at the top politics right
now.
Those are some cutthroat,
cutthroat people.
Even baracK obama didn't get worried was
by playing nice,
you know?
And so when you writing a character
about someone in that higher position of
power,
you have to channel some of that in
there.
There has to be that level of a self
assuredness all the way up to arrogance
and that dismissive nature as well.
You know,
if you're in my way,
I'm gonna tell you probably shouldn't be
in my way because not going to go well
for you.
And then that full on confidence and
then they just,
you just get rid of them.
If you crush them then too bad.
I told you when you start to write a
story,
do you,
do you have like a full idea in your
head before you sit down in front of a
computer or do you have like,
I want to write a vampire cop drama.
Like you mean what,
what is it that.
Do you have a bunch of different ways
that it gives birth in your mind that
it.
It tends to come from several different
places.
I watch and I watch as much science tv
as I can and I read up as much as i can.
And in the,
in the natural world,
there's always something like,
oh my,
look at that,
look,
this creature can do that thing.
The water bear can survive in space,
you know,
holy crap.
And that'll stick.
And then at some other point you will
watch something about,
uh,
you know,
here's asexual reproduction.
If they're in this particular chemical
environment,
then that'll stick.
And then a couple things stick and then
at some point I'll just be working on
something else and four or five things
will come together.
And then that's the center point of the
idea.
I'm like,
well,
what if we had creatures that did this
and then this happened,
and then they took over the world kind
of thing.
From there you have to go and hammer out
an outline.
I try and hammer out an outline with the
tiny bit of science knowledge that I
have.
And then I'm really fortunate again,
because of the podcast,
I started getting people,
scientists emailing me going,
wow,
I love what you're doing.
You're really trying to get the science
right.
You fuck this up.
So if you get into neurochemistry,
again here I'm a phd,
give me a call and like these I started
getting all this shit in and now it's
amazing.
Now I've got this battery of people.
I'll do the outline and then I will send
them all the outline and say,
all right,
tear it up.
And then they,
they shred it,
and they'll come back.
Well you can't do that,
but here's some other.
We just found out about this.
You could do this.
That is so cool.
What an amazing.
And they,
they,
they have a blast with it.
And then I restructure my outline,
do a detailed first draft and then we
repeat for people that are listening
right now to go,
well,
what's his podcast?
What's,
what's the name of your podcast?
Podcast.
Just got sick.
There's audio books and you can,
if you
go to itunes and search for scott
sigler,
s c o,
t t s I g l e r,
you'll find that and,
or scott's lego.com.
We have them there and we've been goIng
on seven years now.
Is that right?
So every sunday for seven years we put
out an episode,
I want you to pull a picture up of those
water bears.
I think they're also called tardigrades.
Tardigrades.
That's it.
Yeah.
They can survive in space.
It's so weird when nature is as crazy as
anything you could ever think of.
Fiction.
Yeah.
And it's just undeniable.
there it is.
Here's a photograph of it.
This is a real thing.
That's why the sciences,
you know,
maybe those things fucking great and
they're super tiny.
But you know,
of course my brain immediately looks
this goes,
okay,
what if that was eight feet long?
Let's make that thing eight feet long,
jesus,
and let's make that hide,
you know,
pretty much bulletproof.
Let's do those two things to it.
For the folks listening and not watching
this thing looks like it looks like a
giant rhino with like a circular diamond
drill for a mouth flashlight.
It is the waY it looks like a super
diamond alien fleshlight and the thing
it looks like a star wars creature.
It also looks like it Has that kind of
like a cotton capon or something like
that.
Like it doesn't look like it's dude,
that thing survives in space so it can
survive in space and the membranes get a
little different when you get down that
that small,
but that's the kind of thing where maybe
a graphic artist who does a lot of acid
could come up with that maybe shows up
and you're like,
that's,
that's my god.
look at it's fucking mouth for the folks
at home,
it's literally got a giant shark mouth.
Wow.
That.
And I see this is,
listen to this,
I just realized this.
I'm finishing up a book called pandemic,
which goes infected then contagious,
then pandemic and,
and there's a creature in pandemic,
uh,
and the mouth is similar to that.
And I just realized that that's where I
got it from,
but I think it's been floating in the
back of my head forever and it's
actually popped out in this book.
Look at that photo.
That is insane.
That is insane,
folks.
It's,
you could find them.
They're called either water bears.
People call them that,
or tardigrades I think is the scientific
name for it.
And they are the creepiest looking
motherfucker.
How small are those things there?
There a microscopic.
They're microscopic.
Yeah.
They're incredibly couple of microns.
I think it's spooky little creatures,
but then you get in that gives you so
many storytelling possibilities.
You've got a creature that seems
insignificant.
You can't even see it,
and yet if you know,
if,
if we suddenly lost her atmosphere for
whatever reason or the kennedy,
the environment changed significantly
and all the humans died,
this thing could still be around and
then this thing could start evolving in
columbia zone may be the universe really
doesn't have a sense of time and just
sets up these little,
uh,
extra seeds laying around genetic
material like tardigrades just in case
you assholes hit that button and nuke
the whole planet sideways.
These little motherfuckers can grow into
something that can survive in a vacuum.
It would start over real quick.
If we got wiped out,
it would.
It would Start over again pretty fast.
I wonder.
I wonder what it would be next.
Would it be dolphins?
Would it be some sort of.
They see this is this shit I thinK about
all the time for the buck.
And odds are you're not going to get any
sea creature for a couple of reasons.
Number one,
no hands.
There's no tool.
Use it.
Number two,
no fire.
The two biggest factors that go in our
tool use and fire.
True.
And then I think you also are not going
to get.
This drives me crazy tO watch a scifi
shows about this.
Men lion lions don't need to evolve.
They're an apex predator.
There's no need for them to change
anything.
For the most part,
it's the.
It's the little things that have to run
from everything else.
and especially with humanity.
I think as we evolved as the biggest
thing was losing the hair and having to
invent some way to stay warm and you
start to use tools to make clothes and
tools to hunt.
And as soon as someThing has to use a
tool and figures that out,
that's,
that's the flashpoint.
From there it goes,
it goes crazy.
Why did we lose the hair?
I'm not entirely sure.
I don't know,
but there wasn't a large need for it in
a greatly temperate environment like
savannah,
africa.
So in the human Body,
all evolution,
if there's something that you just don't
need anymore and you're burning calories
to keep that thing going and it takes
energy to support that.
If you have success of mutations where
that thing gets smaller and smaller,
there's no penalty.
There's no penalty.
Oh well his hands are this big and he
can't use a spear.
You're not going to survive that long.
But if your ear lobes shrink and you can
hear just fine,
there's no penalty.
so this,
the evolution kind of gets rid of the
stuff that you don't need.
It is a
fascinating what you say though about
the intelligent sea creatures never be
able to get like their physical
environment to change.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
That's a.
That's an interesting point.
I never really thought about the no fire
thing.
Did they create it?
You can't.
If you can't
make fire and refined metal than you are
cut off at the knees as far as what you
can do from there.
And James Cameron played with that in
the abyss with having his intelligent
water based species.
But it would be very.
It's very difficult to conceive any way
you could get that going,
so it's your land based,
it's got to have hands or appendages
that are ready to become hands.
Couple of basic things so it could
easily start out with some kind of
primate or some kind of small mammal
right off the bat,
but there's also some pretty kick ass
reptiles out there and
hurts g you hear about the ukrainian
army has been training.
Dolphins can use like knives and and
they've been attaching knives and
pistols to their head and they've
trained them to use them so they can now
use these knives to do things.
Yeah,
so now that right now,
this was on the news today that they
lost the dolphins that had the pistols
are the guns on them and they're on the
loose right now.
So there is these rogue dolphins that
have guns on them that are just
terrorizing the sea.
But come on,
I swear to god,
it's true.
Dolphins apparently swam away to get
laid.
They were out there looking for some
reason they haven't come back.
That's why would they come back?
Guns man guns.
Yeah,
they got guns and they're trying to get
some things or one of the few creatures
that they murder.
Yeah,
they'd kill
for no other reason than just to kill
and also dolphins rape,
which is messed up,
so now you've got these things swimming
around and they're trained to kill
diverse as the problem.
They're specifically trained to kill
divers,
so I'm going to rape a dolphin saturday
at zero than san diego.
Dolphins are trained to kill divers.
They're military.
They're trained to kill.
That's the program.
It's program specific.
Diverse or not diverse.
I'm sure the ukrainian controllers.
This is inherited from the russian
program and they would have specific
parameters to train them to go out and
kill a certain shape or a certain color
or have I fucked up that train dolphins
to go out and be assassins?
Yeah.
What a douchey move.
Well,
these things rule.
Dolphins are very creepy though.
Would they kill babies?
They killed the baby of a.
When a female it gives birth.
I think she won't meet with the mail for
several years.
So if a male comes along and it's not
his babies,
he just kills them.
Yeah,
get a main.
Again,
it's dolphins.
Dolphins are gangs there.
The gangsters of the sea.
They are not messing around except for
killer whales.
Separate killer whales eat them.
nobody screws with the killer whale.
The apex of the apac,
other than humans,
they've got no.
They've got no predator.
There's nothing that hunted.
Killer whale.
I thought happy feet was a kind of a
fascinating monster.
Moving sort of away a monster alien
movie because it dealt with the whole
idea of living in this,
you know,
semi-aquatic world.
All of a sudden these aliens from the
other part of the world from the surface
come and fuck everything up and kidnap
people and take photographs and shit.
And it's,
it's really kind of interesting when you
think about how much life must suck if
you live in the ocean and these crazy
assholes live out above the ocean with
these giant metal machines that they've
created a scoop,
literally scoop life in nets.
Take your right and just,
you don't give a fuck what they get.
Dolphins.
Whoops,
sorry.
Sometimes they get dolphins on purpose.
Imagine what it was like for whales,
which are pretty f and intelligent and
have language for communication and for
what I think 100 million years,
something like that.
There's nobody screws as well because
you can't because they're gigantic and
they just ignore you.
Then all of a sudden here come these
ships and here come these harpoons and
they're screwed.
There's nothing they can do.
Who's the first guy to try to harpoon a
whale?
Fat guy was a bad motherfucker.
You gotta think about that.
Sets a gangster movie.
I'm going to eat.
You know?
I mean,
that guy's not playing games.
I don't know what I've heard about that.
It's probably,
you know,
it's kind of an ice age thing or a place
where there's ice so the whales have to
break the ice to come up to breathe and
a whale breaking through the ice to its
blowhole can get out there.
You just stabbed that son of a bItch and
I don't know.
I don't know how they did it,
but somebody figured out that's a lot of
good eaton.
Wow.
That's harsh life.
Yeah.
Harsh life.
When you get to eat a whale.
The dolphin thing reminds me of.
I've got,
uh,
some of my fans were tweeting today
because that basically the same thing
happens in my book,
the gfl,
so I've got a title fight,
which is what I emailed you
on to start with,
which was an mma scifi story.
And then we have the galactic football
league,
which is young adult series,
but it's an american profile bullied a
800 years in the future with aliens
playing the different positions based on
the physiology.
So you've got like 1500 pound lineman,
you've got receivers and d backs can
jumped 20 feet in the air and it'S this
crazy hodgepodge of stuff.
But uh,
intelligent dolphins are part of that,
that whole thing too.
So it's a that with the neglect of
football league series,
which is the rooKie,
the starter,
the allpro in the mvp.
And then the title fight.
I think I'm one of the few guys is
merging sports and science fiction
because a lot of time the jock is an
authentic too.
Science fiction guys don't like the
jocks very much.
Yeah.
What is,
uh,
what is that story about?
A title fight is a,
it's kind of a classic rocky type story,
but there is a heavyweight champion of
the galaxy and correct the cutter.
And this is octagon full octagon.
it's straight out.
I'm a huge mma champion of the
heavyweight champ of the galaxy.
So in this,
in this,
in this universe,
I have korean sigler verse.
If you're going to be a combat fighter,
you can't have any body modifications.
It has to be all natural.
So there's no hydro,
no,
no hydraulics or no cybernetics or
anything like that.
And he is of a race called the quiff
which have three cats.
There's a leader,
there's a warrior,
and there's a worker,
kind of an insect tile type approach.
And the warriors have these giant bad
ass things with an extra set of arms and
they're very mean and very tough and
they are perennially the champions.
And then along comes this nasty ass
human fighter named kyle north who comes
out of a place called the purest nation,
which is in my universe.
ThiS is the backwater human only world
where they hate all the alien races and
won't get along with anybody,
but they're mean and they're nasty and
this guy's name is kyle north and he was
created by an author named matt wallace
who co wrote this with me and matt to ex
pro wreStler.
So he's a,
he's a bad mf and that it's following
their arcs,
the human who will do anything to be the
champion,
sacrifice his own body,
kill whoever has got to kill,
make any deal.
And the highly,
you know,
almost a ronan like the honor honorable
existing champion.
And the two different,
two Different mentalities clashed for
that final championship ring.
Like the second half of the book is
nothing but the fight.
It's just a brutal fight.
How big is the human,
uh,
in this,
this is trying to.
I'm trying to track out the growth of
humans in just the last 50 years in the
nfl in Particular,
50 years ago,
the average nfl lineman weighed 253
pounds.
At 253 pounds.
You came to play college ball.
Now these guys like the starting opens,
the line for the dallas cowboys 50 years
ago could not get a job anywhere in
football,
probably couldn't even get a
scholarship.
TheY're just not big enough.
So we've seen the average weight go from
2:53,
somewhere like three,
10,
3:15,
somewhere in that ballpark.
And that's not evolution.
That's just better nutrition and these
guys getting the opportunity and
cultivating the big guys because 50
years is enough time for evolution to
kick in,
but eight centuries from now you can
kind of see that progressing out.
So the main character in the black
football league name,
quintin barnes,
he's a quarterback and he's
seven feet tall,
380 pounds and he's.
And theY're like,
wow,
he's kind of small.
He could play tight end,
he'd be a small,
tight end and then I'll.
Everybody's exponentially larger based
on quarterback to lyman.
So kyle north I think is a in the
bookies.
He's six,
eight,
three 80 and that's,
that's the heavyweight champ of the
world.
Jesus christ,
you know,
and just just cut too,
because this is,
this is our cover with them.
So you know,
just looks like gay porn,
so on it does not want to switch that
up.
Why is it so hard?
Why is he flexing so hard?
We grabbed the image and we search for
mma fighter and all the image sites and
that we had a lot of gay part and that's
because all we got like,
you know,
unfortunately and fortunately depending
on your sexual preference,
I was hoping to find just some gigantic
like dan severn type dude and none of
that was available for a million inco.
One of the greateSt of all time.
He did have a body,
anything like that,
his that looks like a james irvin more
but even bigger than james or maybe
james irvin when he was a heavyweight,
he was a very muscular mma fighter,
but most guys aren't built like that
because it's either you have to have
extreme genetics to be built like that
or you've got to spend too much time
lifting weights.
You get more of the law.
I mean you get some really cut zeke's at
the middleweights and light heavyweight.
Those guys together.
Not as much.
You know,
the best guys are longer and leaner,
the really heavily muscled guys.
It's just too much fuel that those
bodies require.
You see,
I'm like a guy like spiders,
spiders,
scott,
you know he's got that cut.
Yeah.
Anderson silva is a perfect example of
what I think is like the ultimate
fighter body,
but occasionally you'll see a guy who's
like really thickly muscled at one 85
and you want to tell them,
man,
listen,
you need to just get rid of all that
muscle.
Just do a aerobics exercises only from
now on.
You have plenty of muscle.
Just wrestle and kickbox and,
and run like a lot and drop some weight.
Man,
you're,
you're hindering yourself by having this
crazy beach body.
You know,
dee dee,
do you think that affects their fighting
performance to be overly muscle?
Certainly.
Absolutely.
It's just not effective.
It's,
it's,
it's like having too much horsepower and
a car where your,
uh,
your brakes can't.
Can they,
uh,
you rather your,
your wheels can't get any traction
because you're just spinning your wheels
and then you run out of gas quick.
That's what happens.
If you have too much horsepower car and
that's how it happens at a person to.
If you have an overly muscular body,
the resources that requires or
substantial,
you've got to pump blood through all
these extra tissues.
That's serious shit.
It's a lot of work for your heart,
so you should be,
as you know,
you should be strong,
but as lean as you can be,
just a natural weight close to natural
weight is great if you can,
if you can,
if you can compete against the larger
guys.
Cut.
Wait,
no,
that's been really cool to watch a wc
come in the nma.
Actually getting more weight classes
because I used to,
you know,
I wrestled at 1:26
in college and there was nowhere when
watching mma,
there's nowhere to see guys have that
size at least until wc came along and
they started to get more of the
flyweight in there.
And uh,
is the ufc going to continue to expand
all to all the way classes?
They're thinking about going to 1:15
as well.
We went to one slash 25,
like yes,
those guys are like,
some people don't like it because they
say those fights aren't as exciting,
but I think for the most technical
fights,
like mighty mouse johnson is one of my
favorite fighters.
Demetrius johnson,
he's the flyweight champion and people
were saying that are the same people
like back in ufc one,
two and three when they're like,
you know,
gracie and would be all tied up with
something like,
well this is an exciting.
I'm like,
it's because you have no idea what
you're looking at.
This is mesmerize dan severn fighting
like gracie is mesmerizing to watch.
I think for some people bigger's better,
especially americans were such
knuckleheads.
We want to see the biggest guy and we'll
see the biggest gun in the house.
It's like John L.
Sullivan can look any man in this room,
you know?
It's like,
that was the say like that lick.
I don't know why.
I don't know why he can't really say
that.
Now I can look any man in this room,
everybody like,
hey,
what the fuck you trying to say?
Man,
I think I was six and I got in trouble
at my grandma's house and my grandmother
was german immigrant and she's like,
I'll give you such a liquid.
I'm like,
I had no idea what the hell she was
talking about.
Like I don't know what's going on
grandma,
but I'm just going to behave from now on
because I don't want to crush it.
That's terrifying threat.
Like,
what are you talking about?
Old woman?
I don't know what you mean by that.
Held me down the liquid.
Get the fuck outta here.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
for,
um,
for fighters,
uh,
the,
the correct weight class and going in
and,
and fighting a to your,
your optimum weight class can be the
difference between being a successful
fighter with a championship career and
being a guy who never quite rise to the
top.
Like you see an mma,
there's a few guys that are like sort of
what I call tweeners by.
They're not really a 1:50
fiber.
They're really too big for that,
but they're really too small for one
seven.
Right.
There's a few guys like that that are
just like somewhere in the middle there.
They shouldn't be like maybe a one slash
65 like bj penn fighting crazy given up
a lot of ways.
Yeah,
bj penn and that's his choice.
Know he just chooses to fight the bigger
guys.
She's not afraid to fight bigger guys.
And when he was younger and he was able
to pull it off pretty well,
uh,
but you know,
the game is moving forward and
progressing direction constantly.
You're never going to slow down the
progress of these young guys that are up
and coming.
They're better,
they're going to be better,
they're going to be better.
They're going to be more technical.
I mean,
it doesn't mean that the older guys
can't still when occasionally,
but those guys have to evolve as well.
You see like in boxing,
like bernard hopkins this week,
one of already.
It's crazy.
I watched it and it's a beautiful
performance because he just did
everything correctly.
He's like such a craftsman in there and
he's,
you know,
he's got these old school sort of moves
and just knows how to cover up,
knows where the punches are going before
you even think about throwing them,
knows what you're going to do,
fines your patterns and then knows how
to step around you and knows how to keep
you moving.
It was beautiful to watch.
Well,
in mma there's not a whole lot of those
guys that are like these old school,
like a perfect fighters.
You know,
anderson anderson's one of them and then
you've got a John Jones who's just as
phenom,
who's,
although he has all this great success
really.
He's got so much to learn still too,
which is the most scary thing about him.
He hasn't even tapped into his branch.
All right.
You know,
and then the really good guys in the 170
pound division,
that's like six or seven of them.
You know,
like this weekend there's six different
killers that are fighting in montreal.
They get diaz's fighting.
George st pierre got carlos.
Condit is funny.
Johnny hendricks and jake ellenberger is
fighting jake shields or no?
No,
no.
Jake ellenberger is fighting.
God dammit.
I got a
nate marquardt.
That's a,
that's a native may.
Neda,
ellenberger and uh,
or jake ellenberger and nate marquardt
is a sick fight.
That's a.
Is that all in the same car?
Same car.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's a lie from montreal.
That's exciting.
How long have you been an mma fan?
Oh,
for ufc one.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
was a big,
big mma fan and it when it was created
this crazy spectacle because that's the
thing like,
wow,
what a ninja beat up a karate master.
And like,
and then somebody said,
well,
let's find out and put everybody
together.
And I remember watching the early oneS
and you know,
this guy's a fifth degree ninjitsu black
belt comes out,
just gets his ass handed to them and a
lot of the guy.
And I was excited because I was a
wrestler and you were watching this
early on and I'd never heard of
brazilian jiu jitsu.
I had no idea what these guys are doing.
But when the wrestlers would come in and
just mop the floor with these dudes,
and it was exciting for me,
it was justifying.
She's like,
great,
yeah,
I took taekwondo and like there's all
these forms and I fully appreciate what
you,
what did you guys do?
but the forums,
I don't get it.
It's going to go flights going to go to
the ground anyways,
and you would watch that and mma and the
fight will go to the ground.
The guys know to do things in the ground
with the guys who would win.
And so really got into it then.
And then when dan severn came out,
he's a Michigan boy and watching his
fights with it and he was just,
you know,
awesome.
Awesome to watch watching him watch,
fight a kickboxer and do full on
suplexes on guys who had no idea what a
suplex was.
And it was beautiful.
So me and all my wrestling buddies,
we'd get together and watch those and
just go ape shit.
We were just like,
we couldn't even get through one of
those without beating the crap out of
each other.
It Was,
it was awesome.
And then to watch it come up and,
and what's happened since dana has taken
over,
it's just been,
it's just been one of the coolest things
I've ever seen.
You know,
it's,
yeah,
it's very strange.
Uh,
as you were talking about the size of
football players changing,
uh,
over a period of 50 years.
Like,
look at how much better the mma fighters
was in the 20 years that has existed.
It's really shocking.
It's shocking the scene now like,
uh,
like diaz and george st pierre,
both of guys to us,
nobody liked them.
Ten years ago they didn't exist.
Nobody was that good.
These guys are on a complete.
This is the highest level we've ever
experienced.
And every time st pierre improves,
like he,
you know,
just be carlos condit had a long time
off and re re cooping from his knee
surgery.
He recovered from that and has the kind
of fighter,
good solid,
long,
tough fight.
Now,
just a couple months later he's going in
there against diaz.
I love that because I think,
you know,
since it's only like four months later
or whatever it is,
he's got time to recover time to rest up
a bill a little bit and then boom,
get right back into it.
So he'll be more use of the experience,
probably put on a better performance,
won't feel the ring rust as much.
Just experienced it recently.
That is that enough time for him to,
uh,
to analyze the other fighters style
doesn't work it in because they're not
enormous on the train.
Has gOt to be.
he's going to do this.
Here's this tendency,
when he puts his right foot forward,
this is what's going to happen.
And you think four months is enough time
for him to [inaudible] that guy's f and
killer man.
He's both guys are killers,
but I think first of all,
st pierre has been [inaudible] for a
long time because they were supposed to
fight before,
um,
the as a tested positive and a marijuana
thing.
And,
you know,
he,
it took him,
you know,
all this time before he,
uh,
was able to get a fight again after the
condit fight.
And so,
you know,
he's uh,
he's had some,
you know,
a bunch of,
a bunch of weird issues like outside of
the cage and that one,
that one being a big one that they
suspended him for a long time for,
for marijuana,
which is just really fucking ridiculous.
That really drives me bananas.
But he's been wanting this fight for
ever.
Des has been calling out for this fight
for ever and george st pierre has been
caged for his fights and talk to you
about fighting him.
And so these guys have been sizing each
other up for a long time.
It's not just four months to get ready.
This is a long time coming.
We played this yesterday.
There's a video of nick diaz hitting the
speed bag for 23 minutes in a row.
It's one of the craziest things I've
ever seen.
He just took 23 minutes.
That is so long.
Most folks have no idea how to get my
arms up for 23 minutes and hit the bag
and he's hammering at it.
I mean,
these guys are both in amazing,
amazing shape.
So I'm so excited about it.
Not just because it's the championship
fight,
because I think it represents these guys
who are to all time great to my opinion,
and it represents them in their perfect
primes.
You know,
they're both in the best situation they
could possibly be.
Nick diaz comes off the bj penn fight
where,
you know,
fantastic performance to carlos condit
fight were questionable decision and you
know,
a,
a close fight,
but carlos condit used a very good
strategy of moving and keeping away from
nick and nick has that aggressive in
your face style.
He wants to commit to a fight.
And George George was not dance around.
He doesn't dance around and with his
wrestling style as well as it can be a
really interesting fight because first
of all,
nick diaz is a nasty guard.
He's got very good sweeps.
He's got a very good submissions off of
his back and it gets real comfortable
there.
He knows how to tie you up.
You know,
it's,
it's not an amateur that you have on his
back and he's dangerous off his back.
You have to mind your p's and q's and
then you know,
it's,
is he going to be able to stop the tape
down?
If he does stop the take down,
You know,
what is the standup look like?
Does george kick them from the outside?
Does nick pressure him into a standup
slug fast?
You know what?
What does,
what does it become?
It's going to be fascinating.
I can't wait.
I'm excited for that fight.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm very,
very excited for as well.
You were like one of the first guys that
I ever heard of that took his books and
put it on the internet as an audio
podcast.
What,
what led you to decide to do that?
I couldn't get a book deal to frankly
going back,
I guess,
geez,
I guess 15,
16 years that I was trying to get
published for about 11 or 12 years,
wrIting,
writing a book every two years,
working a full time job,
all the regular stuff,
and then back in the day,
you know,
actually writing the submission letter
and sending it to publisher,
sending it to agents,
going to conventions,
trying to meet,
make the right connections to get just
to get somebody look at the book.
And I got an agent and uh,
I,
I wound up with a deal with the aol time
warner when my book earthcorps was
supposed to be in every store in may of
2002.
And then the 9:11
recession hit before it went to press
in.
The economy drops in time warner
scrapped everything that wasn't
profitable.
So I'd,
I'd gotten to that point where I had a
book deal.
Then the publisher folded,
it happens and it took me three years to
get the rights back to my book.
So now when I get the rights back in
2005,
I have this professionally edited book.
The other's name was Paul Witt.
Cover was a great guy.
it was a really.
I thought it was really solid piece of
work and we can't get another book deal
for it.
Then I learned about podcasting,
see what dave winer and Adam Curry or
dealing with podcasting and I'm like,
oh,
that's really cool.
Serialized stuff.
So I went to look for audio books to
listen to because the first thing that
happened,
my head being a writer was somebody
putting out serialized books just like
the radio dramas,
the forties and fifties.
I started googling it and after two days
of trying to figure out what I'm doing
wrong to google it and I can't find any,
I then realized nobody has done this
yet.
And at that point I'm like,
I've got a professionally edited book
and it was ready for mass market
production.
Here's thIs new technology that if
somebody hears an episode,
they can immediately,
instant message it to a friend,
email it to a friend,
chat room it,
and anybody who clicks on that is going
to start hearing the story right away.
I've got speed of light marketing with
this and it speed of light,
word of mouth,
and then I'm like,
shit.
And I figured out how to record,
how to make an rss feed,
how to make a website and got it all
done just so I could get out there and
then puts some marketing to work like
the first guy to ever do a podcast,
only novel and hope it will get picked
up by some blogs and different sites.
And it did.
And I started to get a followership.
And uh,
when I got to the end earthcorps I had
three other books done and I just
started podcasting them.
And I've been going ever since.
So I was of the mind that if the
publishers are the gatekeepers and they
won't let me in because it's not a
western,
it's not a horror story.
It's not a vampire story.
They want very specific things they can
sell.
You've got a lot of different genres.
They don't like you very much.
I was like,
if I can get to the end user,
if I can go to the end listener and show
him how kick ass my stuff really is.
I'm betting money that my shit is so
good,
I can give it to you for free and then
they'll still pay for it.
Anyways,
that was the thought process and I
thought I would get a lot of followers
and a lot of followers would turn into a
book deal.
Initially.
That didn't happen because I was going
to publish.
I have 10,000
people listening meet every sunday.
How can you not put this out?
And and their question is,
well,
what's a podcast?
They had no idea what it was like,
here's verifiable stats.
They didn't.
They didn't know what the internet was.
They had no idea.
They,
I swear,
got it.
They didn't know what that happened in
and it was,
and it was ms dot.
I thought I had this awesome plan and
everything's gonna work out great and I
get to the point where I'm supposed to
get the contract and get the book deal
and they didn't care about the podcast
at all,
so then I just kept on doing it and
eventually things kinda caught up.
Finally at the end of the story is we
put out that novel ancestor as a print
book.
The one you've got is the one that's
been rewritten for random house,
but this was just a little little trade
paperback put out by a small canadian
imprint.
One lady working out of her garage,
we put that out on April 1st,
2007 and it was the number one or number
one scifi book and amazon and it was the
number two fiction book on amazon behind
one of the Harry Potter potter novels.
Wow.
In New York,
cracked an egg roll.
I mean it was.
It was awesome because I had a new agent
at that point who had the book infected
on their desks and people are like,
oh,
this is it.
We like this.
This is good.
Then all of a sudden this guy that
they've never heard of anywhere is
number one and for number one inside,
and then that got us into an auction for
infected and then I've been rolling ever
since.
wow.
That's amazing.
What an awesome story.
Yeah.
So you're sorT of self created.
Very,
very much self graded.
There's a love stories like that.
A lot of it,
a lot of it is my,
uh,
my audience.
so a lot of the day when I was,
all right,
we're going to go sell this book on this
day,
spread the word,
and they went out and spread the word.
And this is the audience that you
created with this blog or this podcast
of your novels.
Did you profit off of it?
how did you have it setup?
Did you have to pay for it to download
it?
Like,
no,
it's always been free from square one.
The whole book is free.
that's the model we have now is if you
just want it for free or you can't
afford it.
And you liked the story because
everybody gets into pickles here and
there.
You can listen to every episode every
week and you can get the whole thing for
free.
If you download a book I've done before,
you're going to hear 30 episodes with an
ad inserted before every episode just
like what you do,
so it's going to be ad supported,
free content,
and you can listen to it.
If you don't want to hear me talk before
the episode and you don't hear the ads,
then you can go spend money and buy the
audio book,
so I totally leave it up to the
audience.
If you want to buy the printer by the
ebook,
you can do that.
You want to buy the audio book?
Absolutely.
That's why we're in business.
If you don't want to do that or you
can't afford it,
you can go get all my books,
every word of it for free.
EveryThing on abridged way.
It's been from square one.
That's a beautiful way to do it,
man,
so that way you pay for the bandwidth
costs and all that stuff.
Through the advertising,
everything we've covered everything with
the advertising and advertising has
become a a solid,
solid thing for us.
After seven years we're doing pretty
good with it.
Um,
but largely it's just the,
the general attitude by this whole thing
has been,
I don't think anyone out there mind
spending money for shit that they like.
The problem Is when you buy that record
or you buy that audio book and you heard
the sampling,
you're like,
well,
that was great.
Then you get to the end of it and you're
like,
this guy got lazy.
This,
this story ends crappy.
I have wasted my time.
I've wasted my money.
You're pissed off,
angry that you spent money on something
that you didn't like.
So I flipped that like,
I'm going to give it to you and you're
gonna.
Listen to it and when you get to the
end,
you are going to miss work and you are
going to go all night long and not,
not be able to sleep because I'm in your
skull,
taken over.
And then when they get done lIke that,
I liked that book.
I liked the way that ended.
This is my author.
Then they go buy everything that I've
ever made.
And if people get to the end and they
didn't like it,
it's no sweat off anybody's ball.
It's like,
well,
I didn't spend anything on.
It's not really for me.
It creates this sense of uh,
this crazy sense of goodwill that even
people who don't really like your stuff,
as soon as they hear somebody going,
oh,
you know,
I,
I really like a hard science monster
stories.
Like,
oh,
you got to check out the sigler guy.
And like it,
everybody loves the fact that you leave
it up to the customer and just leave it
up to.
It's up to them.
It's their money.
You decided you want to spend it or not.
It's not up to me to trick you.
That's an awesome ethic.
I love that.
And that's sort of the same thing we do
with this podcast.
We know there's some people hAve like
they have where you sign up and you can
pay x amount of money and access the old
podcasts and some of them have it set up
where if you want to watch on ustream,
you've got to pay for a monthly thing.
but I've always felt like what this
thing does is so amazing is the word of
mouth and the best way to do that is to
make it as accessible as possible,
to put it out there as quickly and as
easy and as to make to make it as
downloadable as possible.
I mean,
if going back to Stephen King,
Stephen King was a start doing a weekly
podcast of his fiction and actually read
his fiction,
he's.
He could charge for that and would make
a significant amount of money for that.
Stephen king's the worst guy ever to
reasonable.
His books are awesome,
but when he's reading them,
I'm like,
oh,
this mother fuckers read books.
Not his thing.
He's not.
He doesn't command it enough.
I don't know.
Maybe you have a strong voice.
Stephen king has sort of most like a
mumbling voice while he's reading his
family are,
would never be able to pull it off.
Well,
the performance of the book,
I've had seven years to polish that up.
when I started out.
The first one earthcorps.
It's like I just use all the voices they
used to use to make my buddies laughed
in high school and like I have no idea
what I'm doing.
Just throw it in there and we'll make it
as entertaining as possible and I've
alwaYs tried to be as make.
Every book is over the top as it can be.
So there's a loud rock intro,
loud rock outros.
I'm peaking the meters when I'm talking
and just trying to make it exciting and
energetic and fun.
He's not just money.
It's people's time.
You're going to take an hour,
somebody time.
You better have some good shit because
they can't get that hour back ever.
Dude.
You're saying all the right shit.
I love you.
That's how you should think,
man.
It would be awesome if everybody thought
that was the biggest thing is the free
because now there's so many
entertainment options.
You know when Stephen King was coming up
in the seventies,
there was movies,
books and tv and that was all there was
and now I got to compete against fucking
xbox and playstation and downloaded
content and podcasts and vid cast and
youtube.
I got to compete against all that just
to try and get somebody to get like,
yeah,
I'm going to go and ask for 10 hours of
your time to read this,
this book.
That doesn't really mean anything.
That's a tough sell today.
That's a super tough sell,
especially with the younger kids because
video games are amazing entertainment
experiences,
you know,
for you to get them to put that down and
pick this book up for awhile,
you've really got.
You got to bring good stuff.
How many hours do you think it would
take to rebuild these books?
You can read one of these and 10 hours.
I think somebody could read it.
Ten,
10 to 20 hours.
Yeah,
10 to 20.
My stuff reads a little.
It's.
It's looks thicker than it is because
there's an enormous amount of dialogue.
There's a lot of regular guy dialogue
and that means like two,
three words,
line two,
line pop up,
up,
up.
Stuff goes real fast.
So people are surprised at how fast they
read it.
Like this giant hunking thing.
They're like,
I can't believe I finished it so fast,
and I'm like,
well,
there's an enormous amount of dialogue
in there.
And this other book that I have here is
ancestor.
WhaT?
What's this one about?
Ancestor is,
um,
an effort by a biotech company to create
a herd animal with transplantable horn,
human organs.
Every year,
hundreds of thousands of people die
because there's just not enough organs
to go around.
And if you've got a bad liver for you to
live,
somebody else has to die.
It's a zero sum game.
So they try and come up with a camera.
It's a,
it's an animal with jeans from multiple
species.
So basically something along the lines
of a sheep or a cow.
But with transplantable,
lungs,
liver,
kidneys,
everything.
A growing body could need if they can
pull this off and put this thing out to
pasture.
It's just like raising cows.
You just harvest them when you need them
and you make trillions of dollars.
This is old school horror movie saifai.
So something goes horribly wrong and
instead of winding up with a 200 pound
hurt animal with a perfectly
transplantable organs and is that goes
out and eats grass,
they wind up with a 650 pound pack
predator and this of course happens on a
remote island in lake superior.
So we wind up with all of our,
all of our characters stuck on an island
with 100 of these 650 pound pack
predators that just go through you like
they go through like a knife through
butter.
These things look like they,
uh,
they're not all that dissimilar from the
american werewolf in london and got out
out there.
But the biggest thing I did with the
night kind of combined,
I'm a little bit of a bar,
a bear and a gorilla,
but the defining thing they have in fans
draw tons of pictures of the feed.
Google sigler,
sigler ancestry.
You'll probably see this.
they have this giant sale thing.
So they've got a variation on the
demetra non-cell fin because it's based
on.
The genome is based on the ancestor of
all mammals.
The thought is if they read,
dial back the genetic clock,
let's get back to the base set of code,
then we will have exactly what we want
and there won't be any dashes,
retroviruses,
there won't be any,
any crazy stuff we can then from there,
customize the animal we want.
Right,
and they.
But they don't get it all the way.
Right.
The thing is is that that's one of the
things it says that's from predator.
Scroll back over to the left.
That's one of my fans did a full four
foot tall mock out of the thing.
That's the monster right there,
and they had the sale fan that they keep
back and you and you start to find out,
they start to use it for communication,
so they signal each other when they're
closing in on you.
So if you see that fin pop up somewhere,
the kind of like a land shark,
your efin screwed.
You're pretty fully there.
Fully cgi in the trailer.
You want to get the trailer out there.
That's.
Yeah,
someone's cgi.
This my buddy kevin copysea,
who's amazingly talented.
Look for a go to youtube and search for
sigler nocturnal trailer,
and so you're doing a a movie of
nocturnal but ancestors to sigler
ancestor trailer.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
Ancestor or this is going to be a tv
series.
What is going on with ancestor?
Nothing right now have been a couple
people have been like,
yeah,
I do trailers for the books.
Again,
trying to compete against youtube.
You've got to be on youtube.
The thing with a book trailer is if you
make a really kick ass book trailer and
it's the kind of thing that people will
share,
the money you spend on that is money
that will continue to work for you.
People keep watching that for years.
Three,
four minutes,
someone dies while waiting for a heart.
Liver,
a kidney.
Okay.
Imagine the technology that could
provide those organs for a fee and
imagine what a company would do to
monopolize that technology.
The biotech firm,
janata tried to solve this problem by
creating the ancestor,
a creature with transplantable human
ordinance,
but they didn't get the dos style
hurting thing.
Instead,
awakened something,
something something very,
very.
You want a monopoly monopoly on human
life.
Nothing sells like life itself.
When we succeed,
we will be the only vendor and be able
to charge what the market will bear for
the millions of people.
Not quite ready for that.
Yes.
The market will bear.
That's my favorite part.
I don't know what that is.
That's sure as fuck ain't no cow.
So you created that yourself?
No,
we.
We had people do the errand proctor a
shot the thing,
but we went out and found a guy to do it
and he got all his actor friends and put
it together in the cgi and we got a.
We got permission from century media to
use in this moments.
Music for it.
We shot it.
We assume that five minute movie we went
out in the mountains and the snow and
had an f and blast doing it,
but that kind of thing.
People still watch that,
you know,
were from 30,
40,
50 times a day.
My trailer for infected at a quarter of
a million views and it just keeps
getting views.
So somebody's going to watch that and
that's exactly the kind of book they
want.
Then they go buy the book.
It's the only form of marketing and the
publishing industry that will continue
to sell books for you year after year.
So we go out and spend.
I spent a ton of money in my trailers.
What?
That's really interesting.
Is this a common thing?
Am I just.
It's getting more leads.
Getting more common.
Yeah.
And a lot of book trailers are.
They're awful.
It's a floating book cover with music
and words floating in.
But there's people who go out and just
shoot them.
I mean,
they do full on three,
four minute movies to try and sell the
book.
Have you seen one of these brands?
Have you ever seen one?
Jamie for this app is.
Yeah.
Wow.
I've never heard that.
That's fascinating.
We did the first one in 2008 and it was
a relatively unheard of.
Now it's more common now.
Professional writer and a man.
I need you to explain to me 50 shades of
grey.
Fuck.
What the fuck is going on?
It's the naughty factor.
I think it's,
it's a I think,
and I'm guessing here,
so I'm trying to figure out primarily
that's a female readership,
trying to figure out the female mind,
which is not something I'm that gift of
that,
but
or gay dudes pretending to be straight.
They might read that.
I don't know,
but I think number one,
it's,
it's not your usual sexy.
This is some stuff we read and he'd be
like,
oh my goodness,
I can you put that in a book and then at
some point it tipped and enough people
had read it that it became,
okay,
you've got the hive mentality.
Well,
got a million people read this.
It's not that bad.
And then the other factor that I think
everybody just ignores is,
I haven't read it,
but I.
It's probably a great book.
It does not sell that many copies unless
that writing specifically appeals to the
people who are buying it and they love
the reading experience.
One of the reasons why women don't trust
porn stars are strippers or prostitutes
or you know,
other women that you know,
will do things along those lines from
money is because secretly I think
there's a fear in the female community
that all would have to happen would be
just a few hundred girls start doing
terrible things.
Then they would all start doing it as a
sort of a mass movement and when a book
like 50 shades of grey comes on and it's
ball gags and you know,
all the crazy shit that doing that in
that book,
go back to the terrible part.
What's shit,
what's terrible about a 200 girls going
out and having a grand old time?
Nothing terrible.
I mean terrible from their point of view
and their own social norms of,
you know,
not wanting to be a slut and not wanting
to be promiscuous.
And in a book like 50 shades of gray can
literally change culture.
I'm sure you got hold of sex and the
city sex and the city.
Same thing.
I bet.
I bet the sales of bondage instruments
have gone up significantly since that
book has come out.
Well,
you think about women in like the
nineties,
like before sex and the city came along.
It was like sort of like there was no
milf world.
There was no,
you know,
there was no.
People weren't like really turned on by
really hot,
50 year olds like that.
That didn't exist.
There was none of that and then all of a
sudden it became okay and then all these
women that were like over 40,
it was like,
fuck it,
I'm getting divorced.
I'm going to go out and get some dick
hanging out with my friends.
I don't like hanging out with many them.
Somewhere along the line they realized
their marriage is a big charade.
I think we're,
we're seeing more,
especially a lot of the porn stars being
more open about what they do and going
on their own podcasts and talking about
like,
yeah,
this is my job here.
This is super fun.
People are accepting it more and more
interested in a book like 50 shades of
grey.
Hopefully the norms of our parents are
are going away and somebody wants to go
get laid and the other person's into it.
What's the problem?
Nobody's getting hurt.
Yeah.
Unless you ball gags.
I'm real tight.
Yeah.
Give her strain.
Sooner or later,
the uh,
autoerotic asphyxiation is gonna kick in
and somebody's gonna strangle get choked
to death.
And that's sad.
Whenever anybody dies from auto erotic
association,
I always smell foul play.
I was like,
whoa,
totally.
You were going to figure out a way to
discredit a guy.
Like there was a preacher that died and
he died.
He had a wet suit on.
He had a black dildo up his ass and he
was doing a autoerotic creation and he
died.
And that guy,
I was figured,
well,
you know what?
That guy is a priest.
Who knows what kind of creepy shit he
did.
You know,
it's probably not a stupid priest,
you know what I mean?
Come on.
Very well.
Stupid.
That's a good way to whack someone.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
But it's a good way.
I mean,
it's like as embarrassing as possible.
Yeah.
The only difference is like you could
make it a little worse by leaving like
pornography around like gay porn or
kiddie porn or something like that.
You crossed me.
I'm elite kiddie porn all around you.
You're going to die about his fixation
mop,
mop mafia,
threatening that.
It'll make something straightened out.
Well,
they said that's what happened with
david carradine that I heard.
I thought the same thought when that
happened.
I'm like,
I don't give a shit what anybody does in
their own private time,
but I'm not buying that.
He crossed someone.
He had to have crossed someone or owed
somebody money or something because it
was just nuts.
Well,
the rumor was that there were some
organized crime involvement in his
death.
That was the rumor.
The rumor somebody easily could have
just made that up.
I mean,
this is so many goddamn rumors,
so implausible that,
that you do that and.
But I've never.
I've tried.
Maybe it's the greatest thing ever.
I'm never going to find us to be
awesome,
but it's not my cup of tea having
supposed to be great to.
I'm not going to do that either.
Brian's dad was trying to get talked
into skydiving.
Tell that story.
Yeah.
His friend was always like,
hey,
you gotta go skydiving with me guy.
Go skydiving.
Skydiving with me.
And then one day,
uh,
she,
her,
a parachute got tangled up with her
emergency parachute.
Oh,
she died.
And this was like a week before he was
going to go skydiving with her.
Yeah.
So yeah,
not for me.
No.
Did he find out by just going into work
and she wasn't there?
Yeah.
Whoops.
Not for me.
More power to the people want to do it,
but not,
not for me.
I avoid the crazy life threatening
stuff.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a funny one though.
Skydiving one's a really funny one.
It's like you want that big adrenaline
rush.
Wait till they come up with virtual
skydiving.
That sounds like it's going to be pretty
bad ass.
Well,
there's a little fan things,
some pretty fun.
Have you ever done one of those where
you're like over that big fan and you're
just kinda like,
yeah.
Floating that said it's amazing.
Yeah.
They have one.
The universal.
We should do it one day.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Hey,
you fly.
Yeah.
It's just like a technique to it too
apparently because if you do it a
certain way you can fall.
Does that give you the same drastic
fight or flight response though as
looking out,
jumping out of a plane?
You're like,
if anything goes wrong,
I'm going to die.
That's the thrill I got to think for
these people.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's,
that's a big part of it.
So it's the part that people don't want
to,
they don't want to sort of admit it to.
It's a thrill.
What's the thrill part?
Well,
the thrill is that you're almost dying.
Yeah.
You're gonna,
you're gonna add,
bungee jump at the same thing.
Your body is reacting like it's going to
die and you're tricking that.
Yeah,
but not really.
Like you're pretty sure it's not going
to.
So it's not a full on,
I'm going to die moment.
Well you only make that mistake once,
then it's,
you're,
you're all set.
Yeah.
We're weird with our manipulation of our
fight or flight responses.
The things we do,
wing suits and shit like that fucking
you know,
organized,
fighting the same thing you are.
You are channeling that base primitive
instinct to establish dominance over
another member of your species.
It's just the.
All of the things that used to go with
that in primitive times are gone and
it's just down to that one instinct.
You are going in there to test your
mettle against another person and a and
see if you can beat them.
If you can establish dominance on them.
That's all that stuff is and the guys
who are the best that establishing
dominance of the guys who rise to
prominence in their,
in their sport and we're starting to see
younger and younger guys retire as well.
That's good.
That's being an issue now is a very
tiring because they've already got
damaged to the retaining ahead of
damage.
Well,
everybody's got a certain amount of
damage.
That's the reality.
The reality is if you've done some
hearts bar and you've got damaged,
it's just no.
So it doesn't seem like there's any
getting around that.
I mean,
how much of it recovers after you know?
A couple of months.
How much is a couple of weeks?
How much has never depends.
I've seen fights where guys got beat up
and they were never the same guy again.
They just weren't that they're missing
something.
They were at,
if they were at 10 before they were at
eight,
now,
you know,
and that was where they were now and
they could have a fairly successful
career at eight,
but they would never be 10 again.
Now that's something the nfl is facing
because they've got 100 years of results
to look at.
But for something like the ufc,
which is new,
you wonder at what point does it come in
when they start to go,
what do we need to increase size?
The gloves are outlaw.
Some of the various actually is um,
less safe.
That's where the bigger gloves is
because they hit harder with know the
beer gloves.
There's two issues with it.
One is that you don't break your hands
as much,
so you could pretty much punch a guy
anywhere.
I'm not always,
some guys have fragile hands,
even with the big gloves like floyd
mayweather,
he's uh,
he's had several operations on his hands
because he kept,
kept breaking them,
whereas I'm,
the mma gloves are smaller and you can't
take as many shots with them.
The bigger gloves you can take more
punches and in fact it's not really
necessarily the concussive blows that do
a lot of brain damage.
It's the just the constant subconcussive
trauma that is the,
it's the real issue.
So,
um,
there's a guy named nick denise who was
a mma fighter who just retired,
I believe he was a premed student I
think,
but very,
very smart guy.
Nonetheless,
whatever his educational background was.
But that was his concern was the sub sub
concussive trauma,
you know,
you start thinking like,
why can't I remember where I put my
fucking car keys?
Like,
is that normal absentmindedness or am I
missing a year now?
And that's a,
that's a,
it's a real concern.
Still safer than boxing.
I mean by far,
right east,
supposedly.
Yes,
because boxing has less options.
Um,
for,
for one,
you don't,
you can't clench in a boxing match.
You're not supposed to.
You can't take out of the ground if
you're stuck in a situation.
You,
as far as repetitive head trauma goes
though it depends how your training your
training is what's really important
because a lot of boxers who are very
smart,
they don't train that hard or as far as
a sparring,
they don't spar hard.
They spar,
like they'll,
they'll get good sparring partners in
the box.
It like a 50 60 percent ratio,
you know,
they don't,
they don't try to murder each other.
Whereas there's a lot of mma gyms where
guys are trying to merge of it and that
not sit.
It doesn't take place with boxing
because there's some camps where it
certainly does,
but for the most part if you're watching
a high end boxing camp where there's a
lot of money on the line,
they're having good,
hard sparring,
but they're,
they're also working,
they're working on,
you know,
a guy imitating a certain style or you
know,
putting a certain amount of pressure on
a fighter or whatever you know,
in,
in the high end camp.
If you're dealing with floyd mayweather,
camp,
camper,
somewhere along anywhere in that range.
You're dealing with it.
They have a strategy to it.
In mma you have a bunch of gems like
that,
but then you also have a massive amount
of gyms where people just sort of making
it up as they go along and they think
the harder you go,
the better it is.
So let's go hard.
We're bad asses.
We're going hard every day and they'll
go hard.
Even to the head.
Like we had boss route nine yesterday
and he was talking about a holland
style,
a sparring.
They would go full blast the body into
the legs,
but to the head they would punches
because they realize,
you know,
you're damaging each other in a lot of
the less experience mma gyms or the less
well-structured mma gyms.
They don't realize that.
And so they,
they're punching each other full blast
in the face and training and they're
fucking each other up.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then that up it adds up.
There's no way.
It doesn't add up.
Like you'll get a guy like alistair
overeem,
he's been stopped something like nine
times,
maybe even 10.
I think this might be the 10th time has
been stopped.
And his career,
that bigfoot fight,
that's a lot of times man.
It's a lot of times of the fight being
stopped from you getting punched too
many times where you're just guns,
you know,
that's not supposed to get nine of those
in your life.
Right.
I don't think in it's supposed to get
one actually has an awful lot.
Yeah.
And you watch and you watch it.
In fact,
after a few of those you watch it start
to affect their ability to fight.
They're not,
they're not the same guy out there.
Oh,
it certainly does.
And especially if they're not involved
in any testosterone replacement therapy
because one of the things about,
uh,
the,
all that trauma is,
there's been a lot of studies that show
that it starts to shut down your
testosterone,
like multiple concussions than it.
Uh,
it shuts down.
It does,
it does A lot of damage to your
pituitary that apparently the pituitary
is quite sensitive to concussive blows
and when you get blasted a bunch of
times they've shown that it starts to
lower your testosterone and start to
make us depressed.
You know,
one of the things that makes you
depressed,
you know,
but it's a scary thing,
especially for a guy like you,
I'm sure who's you make your living with
your mind.
Well,
I,
I'm,
I'm just going to get back into some
like mna bootcamp and stuff and they did
a little crop of guys.
San francisco had an mma course and I
was having a ball doing that,
but I was not not going to get hit in
the head.
Like,
that's,
that's my,
this is my business.
And then when they actually did spar,
I got hit about three times.
I never saw punch him.
Like I don't process that.
Whenever you just did,
I didn't see anything.
Let's go back to grappling.
Grappling.
I can do all god damn day long,
but I don't see punches.
So I'm out.
Yeah.
Well the key is you got to do only with
people who you really totally trust.
You got to do it.
It's hard if you do it with strangers or
if you do it with a guy who's got a chip
on the shoulder,
some,
some guys just tagged them lightly and
all of a sudden you're in a war that can
happen.
And you know,
what do you do?
The istop sparring partner and stuff.
Most of the time guys don't,
most time they just engaged in the war
with the spark writer.
You don't stop them and say,
hey,
what are we doing here?
We're not because you don't trust him
now because now he's swinging at your
full blast.
It happens all the time.
You know,
that was um,
that's,
I think that was one of the biggest
problems in mma in the early days of,
you know,
mixed martial arts camps with guys
getting beat up too much in the gym
before they ever even gotten to the
cage.
Right.
But I,
yeah,
I don't know.
It makes you wonder what is that?
And that's one of those things that I
get into.
Bell outnet,
that galactic football league series I
told you about his size,
speed and strength continue to increase.
Now we're seeing things in the nfl where
it's just,
it's basic physics and you can put all
the patting you on around a guy unless
they do something drastic to improve
that helmet.
When you get more,
the more force that is on bigger,
faster,
stronger bodies are going to produce
more force.
That brain bounces around inside the
head and when you project football
players out to the four and 500 pound
size and fighters up to the 400 pound
size,
it's something you try and try and get
into that.
In the fiction itself too is like what?
What is the average career like when
you're getting hit on a regular basis by
something that can bench press 1500
pounds and can run 30 miles an hour.
Careers like through three seasons tops
and then you're just the vegetable.
There's nothing you can unless you get
in the head and create some kind of
additional structure between the brain
and the skull.
There's only so much that they can do
other than change the rules to stop so
much damage.
Did you,
uh,
in yOur fiction ever create some other
sort of protective wear that people
would wear?
Or did you issue it altoGether?
Which is what a lot of people think
would be the solution to stop a lot of
the head butting each other and smashing
heads will be given to the helmets that
the first time I heard that I'm like,
that's the dumbest thing I ever heard
of.
And then then I started to think about
it a little bit.
And like,
you know,
rugby does not have the same.
It's not the same kind of contact rugby.
You do not get a 15 yard headstart and
take someone out of the picture,
but um,
you know,
a very rough and very physical and yet
they don't take to impact.
I do.
And football players do.
I do some,
some of the magic hand waving with that.
I'm like,
well,
this new helmet technology protects
against this much and then you just
don't.
You don't explain it because if we could
explain it,
we'd be doing it right now.
So there it is taken into account,
but the main character,
quentin barnes,
it's the seven book series.
We've got four books done and by book
five he's already starting to feel the
effects of,
you know,
I stand in the pocket and if I do my job
right sometimes in getting rid of the
ball and standing there when something
that weighs 800 pounds is hitting me as
hard as it can.
That's what you get paid to do and it's
going to start impacting him.
So I'm excited about that.
The last three books start to get into
the character analysis.
what happens when a,
when a,
the ultimate professional athlete,
the top of his game,
things don't,
aren't processing as fast anymore and he
can't make the decisions as quick as he
could in his reads aren't quite as good
as they were before and his body's
starting to hurt.
So follow them all the way from a 19
year old rookie through this league to
the point where he's like,
at some point he's going to have to make
a decision,
do I continue to play and do what I love
and die doing what I love,
which is admirable and going to die
anyway.
So whY not?
Or do you look to the future and be
like,
what are the next 40 years of my life
gonna be like.
So it's gonna be,
it's a huge influence in the book as to
what's going to happen when you just
stop and think about what an actual
football player today a 310 pound man
who can run like,
like literally like a track star of the
19 thirties.
You know,
when you stop and think about the kind
of damage they can do and you sort of
look towards the future and a thousand
years from now,
2000 years from now,
when this drastic changes happening just
the last 50,
60 years,
it's unbelievable.
You look at where the guys are a third
larger than they used to be in just 50
years.
So you extrapolate that out.
Uh,
and of course there's genetic and
physical limitations,
but as jeanette,
as,
as nutrition improves and science
improves and genetic engineering proves
you're going to wind up in the future
pro sports a couple centuries now,
pro sport,
you're not,
I mean,
they're not even going to look human.
They're gonna look like a different
species.
That's how I came up with the idea for
the book is um,
I used to be able to do a little stuff
for espn when I was in college,
like manage the teams coming off the
field or hold a dish and that kind of a
thing.
And I has 126 pounds and Michigan,
Michigan state's a giant football game
every year.
It's huge.
Espn is there.
And my producer out and I'm on the
headset with him and he's gotten me
bringing the teams out of the out of
their dressing room and then he starts
screwing with me because I'm 19,
I don't know any better and he's in my
ears.
You wanT to listen.
If they don't come out at the right
time,
espn is going to lose $5,
million dollars of advertising and
that's going to be on you.
And I'm like,
he was fucking with me because he could
because I didn't know any better and I'm
like so stressed out.
And then let Michigan state out of the
locker room at the point time and all
these giant human beings are coming out.
And then as they're coming out,
they're running,
walking by the door to the Michigan
locker room,
Michigan.
The door lock room door opens up and
standing in the doors.
Greg,
scrap neck.
You ever heard of hIm?
No.
He was six,
eight,
three,
three 60.
It was.
He was an.
It was a giant,
giant man.
Plus he's got all the gear on and I'm on
and I'm like.
And I'm,
I'm a little tinY thing,
I'm freaking out.
I'm like,
oh hell,
Michigan is going to come out.
And he's like,
you don't let them come out of that
locker room.
I don't care what you have to do.
And so I remember he's a giant.
He's sIx foot eight.
I'm five [inaudible] eight.
I'm 125 pounds and uh,
and he goes to step out and I just put
my hand right right on the sternum.
I just stiff arm them and what?
Stop right there.
you guys can't come out of that locked
room yet.
And just,
he looked confused like,
who is this little person?
And he managed to wait and all the guys
were behind him and he managed wait just
long enough for Michigan state to come
out.
And then I got out of the way and they
came out.
but I had,
I wrote the whole concept of the book
and that one moment,
the whole gfl series I had my hand on
this guy's here.
My nose came up to his sternum and I
remember thinking,
man,
it's like he's a completely different
species than me.
And that was an after that I went home
and started writing that book.
Like what if we have different species
playing football?
And the whole thing blew up from there.
Wow,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
I'm lucky I'm alive.
They really are like completely
different species if you're dealing with
those super athletes,
football players.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're getting some really enormous,
enormous human beings now in the
combine.
I read,
I may have read this incorrectly.
They had three guys,
three offensive lineman,
300,
10 pounds who ran for six forties.
If I stand still and they run at me and
hit me like that,
dead on impact.
That's how much force is involved.
I'm just dead.
There's nothing you can do.
It's crazy.
I wonder how many of these,
uh,
up and coming players are more aware of
the risks now because of the past few
years,
all the different stories that have been
coming out about players,
depression,
post,
post career suicide,
veterans probably are.
But you know,
when you are 22 years old and someone's
paying you hundreds of thousands of
dollars to play football and that's been
your dream your whole life,
you're still 22 in your bulletproof.
I think that the rules have to come in
to adjust behavior.
It has to be run from the top down
because these,
these,
you know,
you were 22 and then if I was playing in
the nfl,
there's nobody can tell me anything.
I'm going to go hit that motherfucker
hard as I possibly can.
That's how I make my.
That's how I make my money.
That's how people know me because I'm
the guy who brings the heat.
It's not,
it's never gonna stop from the players
themselves.
And you start to think,
what if I get hurt?
I'll get out,
but I won't get hurt too bad.
I'll be smart.
They also,
you know,
try and remember back to that age,
there is this rationalization of maybe
I'll get hurt and won't be quite as
smart.
I'm willing to pay that price in order
to have this moment right now.
I'm willing to give up years down the
road and at 22,
23,
24,
that is a perfectly rational,
logical decision.
You're like,
this,
this makes sense to me.
It's not until you get 20 years down the
road.
I'm like,
boy,
I'm glad I didn't get any brain damage
that would suck right now.
It's also a thing when you're 22 and you
love playing football.
Yeah.
That's another thing.
It's so very fucking exciting thing to
do as a,
as his mma finding as is a,
you know,
a lot of murder,
certain motocross riding.
There's a lot of crazy dangerous things
that people really enjoy doing and
ultimately that's really our choice.
Should we should have that across the
board.
We're hard wired to go out and seek that
kind of danger.
Evolutionarily speaking.
We're hardwired to go out like we have
to go get into life and death situations
to hunt,
to defend,
to fight off other tribes.
And the people who have those instincts
are the people who wound up living in
reproducing and passing that on.
So as a,
you know,
18 to 27 year old male,
you are hard wired for war.
That is what in a lot of guys aren't.
That's cool.
But a lot of guys have that.
That's what they inherited is like let's
go out and kill some shit and that's in
you.
I had that in me.
I wasn't very good at because I was so
small.
Wrestling was a good outlet,
but you know,
you know what that feeling is like and,
and these kinds of activities provide a
safe,
rational outlet for those things.
But it's in there and it's going to come
out one way or another.
Yeah.
For a lot of men.
So mean.
And then again,
like as you said,
some don't have it in them for a lot of
men.
Yeah,
that's a real issue because it's sort of
just you have a whole reward system set
up and your dna that you have no control
over and you have all these things that
you enjoy and you know,
there's very little outlet for it when
you're working in a cubicle and it's
hard.
It's hard to make your body a free of
the influence of all these interesting.
There's things that can't be
rationalized.
There's just things you cAnnot explain
away.
Like when I,
when I used to wrestle and finally got
to compete against people my own size
because I played football too and played
as hard as I could and did everything he
could.
But I got my ass kicked away a hundred
20,
100,
25 pounds.
When I wrestled going up against guys my
own weight,
I was able to,
you know,
dominate people and just things like a
cross face or it's a,
you know,
it's kind of mean to say.
I guess one of the greatest feelings of
my whole life is I suplex the kid and
broke his collarbone and when I,
when I brought him up,
put him back,
he ran his collarbone and broken.
He just stuck there and it was utterly
primitive.
It was just,
you know,
why would you be happy?
You just heard another human being.
He was a good guy.
I knew him.
He's a nice guys,
but when I that that for that brief
moment,
all the,
all the chemistry inside and everything
else is like,
ah,
that's how you do it.
Does that help
pew and you're writing when you're
writing something like ancestor,
when you're writing about
this crazy gigantic pack predator.
I get into it.
I get into it a ton,
especially in the new book pandemic.
The thought process is we are a modified
by society.
We have a set of rules that we live by a
certain comradery,
helping out our fellow man,
helping our fellow women,
um,
you know,
and,
and are growing culture,
the growing equality of women.
And there's no need to be a douche bag
law by and large.
You don't need to Be a douche bag to and
get along just fine being a good guy and
then take these people who are aspiring
to become these better people who are
genuinely good people and then put them
in the pressure cooker.
When you start to get into it and it's
like you and me,
joe,
are both in this room,
but if I get out that door,
I'm going to live and you're going to
die and if we both here,
stay here together,
we might both die and there's a tiny
chance in my.
That's what I play with a lot is what
what does a person do when their life is
actually on the line and there comes a
situation they have absolutely no
control over.
Do we regress to that lizard brain?
Do we start looking out for number one
and I don't get into it too much like I
don't.
You protect your kids,
you protect your family.
There's a guy,
you've known him for 20 years,
you two are gonna,
you know you're going down together,
but it's largely when the strangers are
brought together,
get a small amount of time to gel to get
to know each other so it's not
completely alien.
It's itself,
it's,
it's one of my group.
Then bring in the 650 pound pack
predators.
What happens?
What do these characters do?
That sounds awesome,
man.
I'm going to read this.
I can't wait to read it.
Sounds like a great idea.
I love your whole philosophy of love,
what you did.
I love the way you became sort of self
actualized by going out and putting it
online yourself and reading your own
books and putting it out in an audio
book form and making it free.
I think it's brilliant.
It's beautiful.
I love the fact that it worked.
I love your whole philosophy on giving
it to people that can't afford it and
you just put a little ad in there.
It's great.
It's beautiful.
It's all perfect.
Great.
Thank you very much for coming on and I
really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Keep her having me on the show.
I've been a fan since the broadcast news
days,
so it really is a big thrill.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
And for folks who are interested in
checking out more of scott's book,
the last name sigler s I g l e r,
I've got nocturnal in front of me and
ancestor.
And your website is scott sigler.com
and it's just scott sigler on twitter,
right?
Yes.
Scott sigler on twitter,
facebook.com/scott
sigler.
We we get out to all the inter webs
everywhere we can get to them.
Will do.
Thank you very much.
And folks
go,
go support.
Go get one of these books I'm reading.
I'm going to start this one tonight.
Thank You very much.
Part of that.
I really,
really appreciate it.
A really fun time and you thank you to
hover a one of our sponsors for this
episode.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com forward
slash rogen,
you will get 10 percent off your domain
name registrations.
Thanks also to audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash joe,
you can get one free audio book and you
will also get 30 days of free
service@audible.com.
An awesome service where you can even
get scott sigler book nocturnal,
right?
It's the only one that's up there,
In fact it contagious and are up there.
They're all there.
You're freaks.
so go there,
go there and get it.
Check it Out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t use the code name
brogan.
And save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
Thursday night,
san diego,
California,
the american comedy company.
Brian red band,
tony hinchcliffe,
yoshi,
billy bonelli,
jason t dot.
whoa.
It's gonna.
Be a hell of a show.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Go down there and check it out.
And if you're around pasadena on
wednesday night at the ice house comedy
club,
it's me are you should fear.
And ian edwards.
All right folks,
that's the end of this episode.
Wouldn't be back in about 10 minutes
with justin wren.
We're doing a double podcast day.
My man's out there saving pygmies.
This shit's gonna.
be crazy.
Thank you,
scott sigler.
I really enjoyed that.
Thank you very much.